good morning everyone in Feud please
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God IND
you with that I open the public hearing
on House Bill 56 and invite the sponsor
Bill thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is representative David Muse and I
represent the city of Portsmouth and the
towns of Newington and Newcastle
I come before you today to introduce a
common sense Public Safety bill that
would do two things first hp56 would
Implement a universal firearms
background check process in our state
and secondly it would establish a
minimum 72-hour waiting
period before a transfer can take place
this bill has two main objectives the
first is to reduce the risk of firearms
falling into the hands of felons
protective order violators domestic
abusers and people whose severe mental
illness has made them federally
ineligible to buy
firearms the second is to help reduce
gun homicides and suicides in our state
by creating a 72-hour buffer of time
that can help people who are in a crisis
or considering
suicide currently in New Hampshire a
firearms background check is only
required when a firearm purchase is made
from a federally licensed Firearms
dealer while a felony in New Hampshire
to sell or transfer a firearm to a
convicted felon enforcing this
prohibition can be a challenge that's
because of a critical loophole in our
state we don't require background checks
for Private Sales that don't involve a
licens
dealer this loophole creates a dangerous
Gap in our law it not only makes it
easier for a convicted felon to obtain a
firearm but also for domestic abusers
and other people our laws have
determined POS a public safety risk high
enough to prevent them from owning a
firearm unlike past attempts to pass a
bill like this the bill before you today
does not try to parse the difference
between a commercial sale and a private
sale under this proposed legislation any
transfer of ownership of a firearm where
neither party is a licensed Firearms
dealer will require a background check
the logic is pretty simple if you want
to buy a gun in New Hampshire you need
to get a background check in New
Hampshire but for most sensible rules
there are always sensible exceptions
you'll find them in this bill starting
on page three line n you'll see certain
types of transfers have been carved out
these include among other things gifts
and inheritances between immediate
family members and temporary transfers
between hunters and Target
Shooters under the bill transfer between
private parties will be facilitated by
federally licensed firearms dealers at
their place of business the role of the
dealer will be to initiate the
background check process to notify the
parties of the result and if the
background check clears to complete the
transfer between the two parties you'll
find the process outlined starting on
page two line
13 another key part of this bill is the
minimum 72-hour waiting period between
the time of background check is
initiated and the transfer of the
firearm to the new owner currently there
is no waiting period and a weapon can be
transferred as soon as the background
check clears under this bill the waiting
period would start immediately after the
initiation of the background check by a
licensed Firearms dealer if the
background check clears the waiting
period would expire 72 hours after the
process was initiated by the dealer to
be clear no transfer could take place
until the background check clears even
if it takes more than 72
hours why at a waiting period because
for people in crisis a waiting period
can mean the difference between life and
death as you'll hear a bit later suicide
attempts are often impulsive singular
tragedies that involve very little
planning Studies have also shown that
some of the factors that incite violence
against others such as anger and rage
can also be very short-lived and can
dissipate if given
time waiting periods provide a cooling
off period for people who might harm
themselves or others Universal
background checks help reduce the risk
of firearms from falling into the hands
of people that are laws for very good
reason prohibit from purchasing prohibit
from purchasing or possessing
firearms for 99% of the population these
changes will basically be a small
inconvenience but for more than a few of
our citizens these changes could be
Lifesavers I ask the committee to
recommend hp56 ought to pass and I'm
happy to take any questions you may have
thank you
representative um represent
PR I didn't see a carve out for uh let's
say uh a woman who just filed a
restraining order because someone
threatened her life I didn't see that in
there that's because it is not in
there and one of the reasons it it's not
in there we we got feedback uh from
different organ from from several
different organizations that um that
particular uh type of provision uh is is
problematic uh many times the uh the
woman won't necessarily have had any
training uh in the use of the firearm
it's also very possible for somebody
who's not familiar with how to handle a
gun or how to handle uh somebody in a
situation like that that the gun can be
taken away from her and used against her
so the bottom line is it's a two-edged
sword any further questions
representative
Sher uh could you tell me what the
percentage of suicides or gun
suicides the percentage of gun suicides
percentage of suicides that are suicide
by gun by gun not off the top of my head
you any further
questions seeing none thank you for
us um at this point I want to let
everyone know that we have um we have
well over a dozen people who are going
to testify today so I'm going to limit
testimony three minutes each please the
time will be kept by the clerk and we'll
let you know when you're about 15
seconds out so please try to condense
your testimony and not repeat what other
people have said if you have a Salient
Point you'd like to get across yourself
with that I recommend I recognize
here yes good morning to the committee
my name is Sue Newman I'm a
representative from NASA ward two um I'm
my remarks will be very very brief
previous representative covered
everything and did it expertly as he
always does I just want to say a couple
of words common sense um I've heard a
lot about common sense over this past
year people running for office our our
president now has said he is supporting
a revolution of Common Sense and to me
background checks has and will remain a
common sense issue years years ago when
I was walking around many parts of our
ward in NASA I asked gun owners and
non-gun owners alike did they support
background checks many were horrified
that background checks weren't required
already but they weren't but people
supported it um driving up here today I
couldn't help but noticing bid trucks on
the road small trucks small cars large
cars whatever the thing in common that
we have we've all got a license to drive
or at least we should so I'm just I'm
going to go I'm going to end with common
sense that if you people the committee
and hopefully the entire house is
supportive and grasps the concept of
common sense I would hope background
checks falls into that as a common sense
measure to prevent and help prevent gun
violence thank you thank you
representative
uh the chair Rec recognize your
Manion thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Tom
Manion I'm representing Hillsboro 1
pelum uh I I'm here to testify an
opposition of
hp56 uh this bill injects federal
government into what should be a simple
person-to-person transfer of property
it's already a federal crime to transfer
to a prohibited person and criminals
don't obey this law this puts
unnecessary hurdles in the way of a
straightforward
transaction between law-abiding citizens
this is to say nothing of the Fifth
Amendment violation that is the ATF Form
4473 where admitting to using cannabis
even medically prohibits you from
receiving a firearm just like every
other gun control Bill filed everywhere
this will have no impact on violent
crime and only punishes those inclined
to follow the law already I ask you to
Slover okay there we go hi hi my name is
Kathleen Slover I'm from Portsmith and
I'll be speaking on behalf of myself
please vote ought to pass on HB
56 on Wednesday April 12th 2023 a young
man posted a video of himself with a
handgun and the text I'm going to shoot
up the school he was in a in his car in
front of Portsmouth High School law
enforcement later recovered his vehicle
in his vehicle an AR-15 rifle a shotgun
camouflage body armor a handgun holster
a Red Dot site and numerous rounds of
ammunition the FBI special agent in
charge said the danger posed by Kyle
Hendrickson in this case was very real
he not only threatened to commit a mass
shooting at Portsmouth High School he
had the means to do it illustrated by
the AR-15 rifle shotgun and body armor
that we recovered inside his vehicle the
man was charged with a felony and
sentenced to 37 months in federal
prison my son was a student at PHS at
the time in fact you can see his
classroom in the video footage um that
was posted it was by a stroke of luck or
some miraculous moment of Sanity on
Hendrickson's part that he didn't go
through with his intention of shooting
up a school that day whether it was PHS
or another school and it seems just as
miraculous that law enforcement was
tipped off and was able to find him
confiscate his we weapon stash and throw
him in jail this man will get out of
jail in 3 years and if he decides to
come back to the Northeast come up the
I95 Corridor he'll have to pass 11
States before he gets to one that allows
him to get a firearm without a
background check that state is New
Hampshire once again the safety of
granite Staters will be dependent on the
whim and discretion of one person the
person deciding whether to run a
background check or not a background
check that would flag him as a felon and
prohibit him from obtaining a firearm
once again our Fates and those of our
children will be decided by luck and
miracles it takes more than luck and
miracles to keep our kids and Community
safe it takes responsibility and
Leadership please vote ought to pass for
Moren
okay um I'm unsure why two wildly
unpopular gun control bills were meshed
into one wildly unpopular gun control
Bill Bill but here we are the background
check portion of this bill was written
by an outstate gun control organization
from California over a decade ago
there's a reason it has failed all these
years the bill makes it impossible for
women and others to get gun safety
training classes from anyone other than
multi-billion dollar Corporation or the
few ranges that have gun shops attached
in New Hampshire in those cases the
costs are increased and that impedes
low-income women the most this bill
makes it unfeasible for most private
instructors to teach gun safety training
which is what the people proposing this
legislation claims they support you
cannot claim to be for gun safety then
push legislation that does exact the
exact opposite of supporting gun
safety on to the second part the
mandatory waiting period the proponents
of this legislation claim it's to curb
Those who commit suicide using a firearm
the fact that this bill targets only
those who purchase firearms and does
nothing to increase suicide awareness
awareness or propose more help for those
who may feel suicidal shows the bill is
about control and not helping those in
need it's not that they care more about
the people using a firearm for suicide
over Those who commit suicide in other
ways it's about control there are are
women who have had to get a firearm in
emergency situations some to protect
themselves from violent stalkers or
abusers like you were mentioning
chairman waiting three days to a
purchase a firearm would have resulted
in those women being murdered this bill
would enable their
murderers according to the New Hampshire
DHS HHS site the number of suicides
decreased in 2023 I think this is an
excellent Trend we can all agree on most
likely it's due to getting people the
help in resources they need harming
others who seek to protect practice
their fundamental human right to
self-defense especially women where it
can literally mean their life or death
does nothing but Implement Draconian gun
control measure measures that have no
place in Live Free or Die in the Live
Free or Die State especially if you
claim to be for women's rights please
vote inexpedient to legislate on this
bill it do does nothing to increase gun
safety or decrease suicide and it does
everything to decrease the safety of
women in New Hampshire thank you thank
you for your
testimony sure
ahead excuse me uh I'm going to keep
asking the same question till I get an
answer from somebody do you know the
number of suicides that are suicide by
gun um you know what I looked re did all
kinds of research in New Hampshire and I
couldn't find it on any of the websites
there was 21 suicides in New Hampshire
in 2023 and the last time when I did
find the STA statistics it was about
half so it was about 50% um the last
time I looked which was a couple of
years ago same Bill thank you you're
welcome to save you from having to look
that up further I believe it's available
on the FBI's website um who's
good morning thank you for hearing my
brief testimony my name is Marcela duie
I am a volunteer member of Mom's demand
action I am also the suicide prevention
Demand I'm going to try and keep it
under three minutes and if it's possible
if I can yield my time to someone
else
okay a waiting period law requires a
certain number of days to collapse
between the purchase of a firearm and
when the buyer can actually take
possession of that gun by delaying the
immediate access to Firearms waiting
periods can create an an important
cooling off period that can help prevent
impulsive acts of gun violence including
gun homicides and gun
suicides the immediate purchase and
acquisition of a gun allows people to
act on temporary emotions and
impulses which can increase the risk
risk of both gun suicides and gun
homicide suicide attempts are often
impulsive singular episodes that involve
little planning many studies suggest
that most suicide survivors contemplated
their actions for only a brief period of
time often less than 24 hours before
attempt waiting period laws which create
a buffer between the time of a gun
purchase and a gun acquisition can help
to prevent impulsive acts of gun
violence and for those who are worried
about the women who need to protect
themselves against their abuser this
would
also uh Pro protect her if somebody
needed to buy a gun and they wanted to
um attack their domestic partner Works
in both ways um studies suggest that the
waiting period laws are associated with
reduced rates of firearms suicide by one
estimation waiting period laws May
reduce firearm suicide rates by 7 to
11% waiting period laws also appear to
reduce gun homicide rates one study
found that waiting period laws that
delay the purchase of firearms by only a
few days can reduce gun homicides by
roughly
177% and just to keep this short
I would just like to briefly list one of
20 a few of 22 states that have waiting
periods California 10 days Colorado 3
days effective October 23rd District of
Colombia 10 days Florida 3 days Hawaii
14 days Illinois 72 hours Maine 72 hours
New Mexico 7 Days Rhode Island 7 days
Vermont 72 hours Washington 10 business
days thank you very much for hearing my
testimony I am in support of this
Bill thank you for your testimony thank
you the chair
gas thank you Mr chair honorable
representatives of the committee for
record my name is representative Henry
gon Hillsboro 29th
District I'm uh going to oppose this
bill and I would hope that this body
would itl this on the on a few
grounds uh one of them
is it is the duty of this body to
protect the rights of the people the
rights of the people have been
delineated and our referen multiple
times in our Bill of Rights and
throughout our constitution of the state
and of the federal government there is
no other right where you have to apply
for permission to exercise it you don't
need a permit to keep your house free of
illegal searches without warrant you
don't need a permit or training class to
go to church or to stand outside of our
Courthouse here today with a sign that
expresses your opinion you don't have to
have a
permit in order to be free from
government prosecution without due
process but we're asking people to have
waiting periods and in cases permits to
exercise their in alible rights it is
the duty of this body to protect the
rights of the people and that is where
the duty of this body ends thank you for
testimony the chair recognizes Kate
giddens
good morning everyone um I represent uh
women for gun rights I'm the state
director here in New Hampshire and I
just want to throw my weight behind uh
the testimonies of all those opposing
this bill today and just add to that um
that the the redundancy of this bill as
there are already multiple laws in place
in New Hampshire and and on a federal
level that prohibit um the possession of
firearms Arms by people with uh who have
been deemed mentally defected or they're
felons uh you're not allowed to give um
guns to miners there are already
penalties in place for that and to point
out that if you want to buy a gun in New
Hampshire you need a background check
that is true that's exactly what happens
if you want to gift a gun if you want to
transfer a gun that is up to the
responsible gun owner and them alone
there are already laws in place that
will pen ize them if they do the wrong
thing the responsibility is on them to
make the right decision and I also want
to note that um it's not known that
felons and mentally ill people go by the
book um this bill will
actually not do anything to stop that uh
drug dealers and people looking to
commit crimes will not go together to
their local FFL to fill out paperwork
and hand over their details it's it's
just not how it life works if we're
talking about common sense um and I also
just wanted to point out that this type
of Bill would leave women quite
vulnerable um one in six are stalked one
in four are raped one in three are the
victims of domestic violence if they
should need to um have protection they
ought to be able to get that as quickly
as possible and I did just want to
quickly mention I wasn't going to say
anything about suicide um but just for a
touch of reality where I'm originally
from in Australia where guns were conf
confiscated um back in
1996 uh the effect of that on the
suicide rates is that before that time
uh suicides were mostly about 50% by
firearm um nowadays uh that is just
replaced by hanging they find a rope or
a belt or something like that and they
do what they intend to do so actually
where suicides are concerned and
lowering the suicide
rate unfortunately it's so very sad but
if people want to do that they will find
a way to do that I'm sorry to end on
that note but that concludes my
testimony the chair calls Nick pinich if
right thank you chair committee for
letting me speak my name is uh ni
penovich I'm a retired U trauma surgeon
I was a general and vascular surgeon
conquered hospital but during 40-year
career which ended about a decade ago as
far as taking direct care of people it
was uh always saying being on call um
being available at night take care of
trauma most traumas were and gun trauma
were at night um to answer represented
sher's question um I think the data that
I were on suicide guns and so forth uh
Hospital data you know when people get
to a hospital if it's a suicide
attempt uh and PE taken all the suicide
attempts whether they're successful or
not dying uh it's about 5% were involved
with guns and most people still take
drugs or I hanging maybe in Australia um
but if you do use a gun you're more than
50% successful so the debts if you take
all the suicide debts that the hospitals
deal with more than a little over 50% of
them are guns so that that's pretty up
to dat data I think uh even though I
haven't operated on anybody and for
trauma in a decade I still teach I'm up
tomorrow today in Lebanon with medical
students and residents this morning in
conquer so I'm still teaching and trying
to keep up to date uh a little I just
want you to my perspective um it's a
different persective because once
Badness happens with a gun or without a
gun we're there but Mo we surgeons with
a gun when Sandy Hook happened in
2012 one of the pr surgeons I train with
his name is Lynn Jacobs head of at
Hartford chief of surgery and Trauma
he's a guy that got the call about Andy
hook all those kids being damaged and
the first call was be ready uh CU
there's a lot of damage here we don't
know how bad it is the second call was
uh half an hour later where he called so
what's happening the answer is forget it
they're all dead and he was asked the
next day to go down and look at all the
autopsies and that generated an interest
in the American College of Surgeons my
educational not so much a union group in
DC but a big educational group and
within about 6 months the College of
Surgeons of which I'm still a member
representing myself basically came out
with uh stop the bleed so when you look
at an AED in a high school or anywhere
there's a tourniquet there that's all we
did in other words said let's stop the
bleeding as well as uh being able to use
the AED however it also started a
commission that reported in 2017 five
years later of surgeons and they they
picked asked many trauma surgeons from
major trauma hospitals con Dartmouth had
a represent did not have a
representative on that but they made
sure that the 15 people on that
Commission 13 of them were members of
the
NRA so they wanted to see what surgeons
who were members of the NRA wanted and
this type of bill was number one on the
list and they're still pushing for that
in Congress and so forth so it's a
different perspective I know it has a
lot to do at rights but those of us in
the trenches Grant I haven't been there
in 10 years have a different perspective
that I wanted to share with you we clean
up the mess and try to save
lives that's all I have to say any
questions
see none thank you very much for your
Davis good morning chair honorable
members of the committee my name is
Justin Davis I represent the National
Rifle Association here in New Hampshire
I am a New Hampshire resident as well um
as already noted this bill combines two
perennial failed bills from California T
gun control into one which which is a
pretty interesting political tactic to
take but we'll kind of split this up
into two things waiting periods as well
as the universal background check bill
um so as noted uh this bill would set up
a three-day arbitrary waiting period for
folks who already go through a legal
background check so you go to your local
FFL you buy a new Glock you go and you
get your background check you pass your
background check well now you have to
wait three days for the sake of waiting
three days um this denies an individual
right to their urgent self-defense as
noted women who are uh endangered from
an abuser who need immediate
self-defense are in particular for this
uh although they can obtain a piece of
paper that says a protection from abuse
order as we've seen before that does not
always result in a safe situation um it
also has a major impact on the economy
uh New Hampshire's home to over 10,000
2A related firearm jobs that creates
over multiple billions and dollars in
economic impact um as you probably know
Maine has also passed a saving to our
waiting period uh they've had a 10%
decrease in background checks which can
kind of tell us about the firearm sales
ironically enough they've also B passed
a universal background check um in
response to that New Hampshire seen a
10% increase so what we're seeing here
is that individuals will uh leave the
state to buy firearms folks who come
here for hunting Recreation who may come
here to buy a firearm to hunt will no
longer come to New Hampshire to hunt
further impacting our Ral economy so
this is beyond a public safety issue
it's also a very real Financial issue um
regarding Universal background checks um
folks who say that you can buy firearm
in New Hampshire without a background
check are are really misleading right so
like we said before if you go to an FFL
you have to pass a background ground
check um and folks who do private
transfers uh are very aware that if you
uh transfer firearm to a prohibited
individual well that's a crime so
typically a lot of these transfers are
friend to friend family member to family
member and folks who may not know the
individual can still go to an FFL and
get that background check right they'll
pay maybe a $50 fee for a transfer fee
that background check will be run and uh
that will be processed through there by
mandating this uh once again you're
really harming the ability for folks to
have the New Hampshire tradition of
lending a firearm to a family member or
friend selling a firearm to a coworker
who they know are not prohibited um and
there's also this idea that you know
criminals are going to do private sales
and buying it from somebody through
without a universal background check
well the Obama Administration actually
found that 90% of crimes with a Firearms
were actually used through straw
purchase and theft once again you put a
universal background check law in place
individuals who are criminals who by
definition will not follow the law we'll
find ways to obtain firearms and simply
put a burden on law- abiding citizens so
I'm happy to answer any questions you
have I know you have a lot of testimony
short representative
cells yes thank you for taking my
question of course a lot is made for the
lack of control here in New Hampshire as
far as the
transfer uh of
firearms do you have any statistics
comparing New
Hampshire's um
uh rate of uh uh firearm uh uh deaths as
compared to a more strict State such as
Connecticut or New York or California or
Illinois do you have any statistics how
does New Hampshire compare where the
Live Free or Die State how does New
Hampshire compare to some of these more
strict States absolutely I appreciate
that question well I'm sure all of you
know on criminal justice that New
Hampshire is proudly the safest state in
the country right so for criminal
activity there's no better place to live
if you want to be safe than New
Hampshire and the opposite of that if
you go to places like California or some
of these places that have very high
levels of gun control they're much less
safe by a per capita standard as well as
a violent crime rate I don't have those
off the top of my hand I'm happy to
compile a document and provide that to
the
committee thank you and um just for
everyone as I said to the professor um
very detailed statistics are available
on the web FBI website absolutely
representative
Bart thank you Mr chairman for allowing
me to ask the question and thank you for
taking my question course could you tell
me what the average time it takes to
have a background check
performed typically it's it's the
national instant criminal background
check system for a region so what
happens is you fill out your 4473 it
goes to the FFL they running through the
FBI system it it purely depends a lot
what you fill out your name I have a
very common name I'm one of the on
Fourth Justin day was the fourth so
sometimes it can take a little bit
longer uh but typically you're in and
out in several minutes uh sometimes it
can take longer the FBI can delay that
transfer if there's an issue um but it
is a national background check system
through the FBI that is meant to be
instant thank
you thank you for your testimony thank
um honorable chair and members of the
committee my name is Simon Thurber and
I'm from exitor New Hampshire um I trust
that we're all gathered here because we
all have the best interest of every
Granite stator in mind uh and what tops
the list of best interest here is saving
lives uh saving lives of children saving
lives of veterans saving lives of all
Granite Staters New Hampshire residents
also cherish their freedoms but to be
able to enjoy our freedoms we have to be
alive
first New Hampshire ranks ninth lowest
in gun death rate according to the
gord's law Center ranking ninth out of
50 states sounds good but it also means
that almost 20% of states are doing
better than New Hampshire I don't want
to settle for the nines I want New
Hampshire to have the lowest gun death
rate in the
country now how can we lower our gun
death rate and improve our
ranking uh how can we save at least some
of the 141 lives that are lost to gun
violence in our state on the average
every
year we may start by seeing what our
neighbors are doing five of our
Northeast neighbors Massachusetts Rhode
Island New Jersey New York York and
Connecticut have a lower gun rate death
rate than New Hampshire and what do they
all have in common they all conduct
Universal background
checks in New Hampshire licensed firearm
dealers conduct background checks but
firearm sales at auctions gun shows and
between private citizens don't follow
these same high
standards to save lives all firearm
sales in New Hampshire with obviously
some exceptions um should include a
background check all parties should
behave as professionally as licensed
dealers we know Universal background
checks save lives Granite Staters know
that background checks do not infringe
on their
freedoms healthy law-abiding citizens
who purchase a firearm wait only a few
days which is a small ask for a life
saving
benefit and now let me talk about
waiting periods a brief waiting period
would also prevent many deaths by
suicide most firearm deaths are suicides
and most suicide attempts take place
within minutes of a person's decision to
end their lives and besides there is
about
90% 90% of suicide attempts with
Firearms are lethal so those people
don't get a second
chance
um and I have a copy of a peerreview
journal here that I'm happy to share
with you I've also at the bottom of my
testimony list the reference that
according to Clinical Psychology and
Psychotherapy an overwhelming number of
suicide attempts happens rapidly from
the decision to die to actual attempt a
third over third 36% of people act
die uh please vote in support of House
Bill 56
56 thank you thank you for your
man the chair recognizes The Honorable
good morning honorable members of the
criminal justice committee my name is
Jonathan Stone I reside in clam New
Hampshire I have a business of Black Op
arms where I'm a partner and currently
serve as the operations manager and NFA
compliance officer I'm here to uh rise
in opposition of this bill and also to
maybe answer any questions you might
have on the actual realities of
background tricks in the state of New
Hampshire perform on a daily basis uh we
have to differentiate excuse me between
the state background checks that are
done on handgun purchases and what's
called an
in addition we also do the Nyx checks
that are done by the FBI with long guns
and uh waiting periods in my opinion are
very unnecessary uh burden for many
people and for many reasons does not
improve the quality of the background
check uh I do have the experience over
the last 13 years of having women coming
in seeking out either Firearms a
combination of firearms and non-lethal
weapons such as tasers and pepper spray
to hinder anyone's ability to P to
purchase firearm is really unacceptable
uh New Hampshire does not really have a
gun problem uh we have very low gun
crime we have very low uh rates of
suicide when it comes to guns when
compared to narcotics such as fentanyl
in addition uh you see a lot of people
in a gun culture of New Hampshire that
are responsible citizens they are not
going out committing crimes
unfortunately most of the guns that are
stolen or traded end up in the state of
Massachusetts which is a well-known
document in fact with most of law
enforcement and I see this bill is
pretty much the same as as it was last
year and I often ask myself if anyone
from law enforcement comes in to testify
in support this of this bill or even
requested this bill from the prime
sponsor I would eventually that would be
a no uh if you have any questions I'm
willing to take them but I would
recommend itl this bill
immediately thank you for your testimony
do I have to push a button is this it's
good okay thank you um well I'm here to
explain why a waiting period would have
saved my son Nathan and I'm sorry I
might go over 3 minutes recently I
received two texts from Nate on the same
day one was to wish me a happy birthday
and the other was to say goodbye and
that he loved us and he was sorry then
he called 911 to report a suicide at our
house he hung up the phone put a gun to
his Temple and pulled the trigger the
gun he used was purchased legally just a
half hour before the hooks at police
arrived first and they found that he was
still breathing and then an ambulance
came and they took him to the Elliot
Hospital where he lived another 2 hours
in pain when my husband and I arrived we
were ushered into the family room of the
ER and a moment later they told us um
they were moving him to the ICU so we
rushed out to see him and there were
nurses all around his head like walking
alongside the
gurnie um I thought oh thank God because
they're working on him but really they
were just hiding us from seeing him when
we reached the ICU a neurologist told us
that Nate had no chance of survival
there was no significant brain
activity keeping him alive was causing
his body even more pain even though he
had no brain activity the neurologist
told us that he was in pain from this
gunshot they told us he was going to die
and they asked us for permission to just
let him go so I asked to be with him and
just hold his hand as he died and tell
him I loved him and what a great son he
was um but they said no because it was
too
traumatic I said I didn't care but they
they said no so he just told me that he
lost most of his blood through the wound
in his head and they couldn't clean it
so my son died
Alone um I found out later that the
bullet broke his teeth that his eyes
were bulging and bleeding from the
pressure and there was brain matter and
skull pieces around the exit wound
that's what they didn't want us to see
that's what a gunshot does and I'm
telling you this to instill in you that
a gunshot is not what you see in the
movies Nathan was in pain if he had any
idea what he was going to have to go
through or any idea what we will be
going through forever he never would
have done this he wouldn't
have um if you lined everybody you knew
up in order from who would be most
likely to kill themselves to Le most
likely Nate would be at the end of that
line he had everything to live for he
was a senior at WPI going to be a
mechanical engineer he had countless
friends a family who loved him I mean
you could go on and on but he had
everything he he was just very chill but
the Catalyst was like it is for many
people a
breakup the girl he loved broke up with
them just days before and he was
planning to spend his life with her so
he was just not emotionally sure enough
to know how to deal with the pain and at
that precise moment he felt that the
pain would never go away he wasn't in
his right mind so to speak our society
seems to think that only people who have
mental illnesses or use drugs or have
this hatred of people who are evil will
either kill themselves or kill someone
else but that is not true Nate suicide
like so many others was spontaneous he
was grieving a loss he was hurt and he
was young and he didn't know how to work
through any of
this if he would have chosen any other
means to kill himself besides a gun he
would be alive remember he was alive for
two more hours after shooting himself in
the
brain an emotional loss triggers violent
behavior in many of us I mean okay like
most of us like many of us have said
things that we don't really we regret
later not terrible things but we might
regret them we might do things that we
regret and say oh I wish I didn't do
that but I was really upset now this is
this bill is for someone who is at the
other end they're just too the emotional
pain is too much for them to
handle um so the idea is to just give
people a moment to take a breath before
they make any rash
decisions now my husband and I are gun
owners we have a gun safe so our kids
can't get to it and that was not the gun
he used he drove 10 minutes away to the
local gun shop and he bought a gun in
minutes and I do not blame the gun shop
they did everything that they were
supposed to do they were ethical they
were they followed the law he was 21 he
came in to buy a gun he didn't have a
record and they sold it to him but if
the law would have made him wait just a
couple of more days even 24 hours he
would have been able to make a rational
decision on if he wanted to really end
his life even if the result would have
been the same even if he still would
have used that gun to take his life he
would have had time to think critically
about the
consequences applying for a gun but
needing to wait would have given him
time to think about his decision he had
friends coming over that weekend it was
my birthday we were going to play games
we had Settlers of a Katan all set up
but he was alone in the house and he was
faced with a crisis and he didn't know
how to get through it the easiest thing
for him to do was to go to the gun shop
buy a G and just end his life ended the
pain it was Split Second and I know that
the Second Amendment says we have the
right to bear arms and I fully support
that I also know and support the Ninth
Amendment which says that we have
additional rights that are not listed
and one of those is to be safe and the
New Hampshire Constitution um provides
you with the authority to make sure that
our general welfare and our common good
is safe so our safety can be balanced
with our rights for the common good of
New Hampshire
citizens I'm asking you to vote in favor
of this bill Nate's friends and family
and the entire Community suffer every
day from the loss of an amazing human
because it was just too easy for him to
get a gun the world was a better place
with him here and I know passing the sun
isn't this this bill is going to it's
not going to bring my son back but it
could save the Sons and Daughters of
other New Hampshire citizens so I'm
asking you to protect their lives and I
I just wanted to answer your question
sir um that it is um I I had looked
these up before it is someone else
mentioned it's about 50% of suicides
deaths suicides are by gun deaths it's
54.6 4% and in New Hampshire in
2022 there was um 247 suicides um or 249
suicides and 147 were by guns so I hope
that helps you and I don't know if you
have any questions
no thanks thank you for your testimony
thank you and I I appreciate you taking
my testimony and not cutting me off
that's
Hank good morning my name is Dr John
henk and I'm representing the New
Hampshire Psychiatric
Society in support of HB
56 I have worked as a psychiatrist at
New Hampshire hospital for many years
gun violence has become a Public Health
crisis and it is
preventable the New Hampshire
Psychiatric Society advocates for
legislation to reduce deaths related to
gun violence including background checks
and mandatory waiting
periods the use of a gun greatly
increases the risk that violence to or
others will result in a
fatality in 2023 in New Hampshire 85% of
gun deaths were
suicides choosing a gun as a method of
suicide makes it much more likely that
the individual will die compared to
other
methods so other words when you use
another method many times the person
actually survives but when you choose a
gun as the method the majority will be a
fatality um and you know sadly guns are
now the leading cause of death for us
Children and adolescents as of
2020 Studies have shown that background
checks can reduce gun violence by
prohibiting Firearms to highrisk groups
including individuals with mental
illness who have been adjudicated with
due process to be a threat to themselves
or
others Studies have also shown that
mandatory waiting periods can reduce gun
suicides and
homicides by reducing the likelihood of
impulsive
acts lowering the chance a person in
crisis of getting a
gun sto ing sudden decisions to commit
violence to self or
others and increasing the chance that
the Suicidal Thoughts will actually
subside over time and we see this many
times in our practice of Psychiatry
where someone in the moment is suicidal
but with the passage of time they change
their minds and that's very
common um please vote in favor of HB 56
thank you for your time and
consideration thank you for your
testimony this morning I'm happy to
answer any questions you might have I
see no questions thank you oh thank
you is there anyone else wishing to
testify this bill who has not testified
yet Ser if you're going to testify
please pull out a card now if you plan a
okay
wow good morning uh thank you for
listening to me today my name is Joe
Hannah I'm the vice president for
Gunners of New Hampshire uh I'm speaking
in opposition to this bill probably for
about the 12th time since I've been
coming here uh this bill is a perennial
favorite it seems um this does create an
undue burden for people who wish to
exercise their rights um you know we
don't we've heard the expression a right
delayed is a right denied and that's
exactly what this is is doing to people
there's no different than uh First
Amendment rights being U Abridged by
delaying permits or allowing people to
to exercise their first amendment rights
the argument's been used that oh we
can't necessarily let people exercise
the First Amendment right sometimes
because violence may happen we've seen
Cities Burn people get killed uh
property destroyed Mayhem ensuing uh but
we still don't deny People's First
Amendment rights because there are Bad
actors among them because bad things
happen we don't get rid of natural
rights that everyone is
deserving um
by delaying these rights we are
increasing dangers to people we've heard
people talk about uh domestic violence U
AB survivors um people that are in
natural disasters people are um you know
left alone to defend defend themselves
police don't show up I've been in
natural disaster areas I've been in U
multiple hurricanes and tornado zones
flood zones uh and there's a a very very
tense period in those those places like
people are experiencing LA right now
violence is is an AB absolute threat if
people don't have um a firearm in these
instances they go out and buy them after
some of the the incidences in the last
few years
um background checks have increased by
up to 500% over short periods of time
after some of these incidents in certain
places so people are waking up to the
fact that hey I need to protect myself
but when they get there the number one
thing they experience is well you have
to wait this long in this state or you
have to wait till the background check's
on some people don't even like waiting
for the the actual instant background
check which you know can't do much about
that but if you have to wait longer to
get your property we don't do that for
just about anything else you can get
your you know narcotic prescriptions
right away as soon as you get your
prescription filled you can buy your
pressure cookers all kinds of stuff that
could cause major problems no one's
doing this
uh Madison the person who actually wrote
wrote a lot of this um in in the
Constitution said that property um he
has a property very dear to him in the
safety and Liberty of his person so
property rights aren't just about
tangible things that we own they're
about our own individual selves and what
we have a right to do we have a right to
defend ourselves we have a right to
protect
ourselves and increasing the time to
allow that to happen is an inherent
violation our natural rights that's not
just against the Second Amendment it's a
First Amendment issue and it's a it's a
property rights issue so I I beg you to
please um itl this bill and I'd be happy
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you is that this
bill the chair calls representative s
ORS
thank you Mr Excuse me chairman and
committee so uh I had the lady Liv not
too far from me when I used to uh work
in New Jersey I was working in Manhattan
and her right to a firearm was delayed
she was being
stalked and through repeated requests
she was continually denied and
eventually her stalker and ex-boyfriend
did kill her as it's already been said
these laws that delay Firearms to
law-abiding citizens have no effect on
those that want to commit harm in the UK
when they banned firearms and they kept
Banning Firearms people used kitchen
knives baseball bats whatever was
available so we need to realize that
currently there are 32,000 laws on the
books and these laws do not stop those
that want to do
harm uh they'll run you over with a car
more victims are the result of a hammer
in this country than with Firearms we
have all these laws they do no good ice
just picked up somebody in Boston
recently illegal immigrant from the
Dominican
Republic he had an
AR-15 multiple pistols a million dollar
worth of fentanyl where does
somebody excuse me once again where does
somebody from the Dominican Republic
that's here
illegally get all these
weapons I mean once again delaying
somebody's right to a firearm is not
going to solve the
problem there are a lot of people in
this country if they wish to do harm
they'll do harm thank you very much I'll
take questions if you have
any thank you and I'm glad you got a
Raymond my name's Ray Banger I'm from
Tilton New Hampshire
um I remember back years ago I got
called the jury duty in lonia for a
woman who was on trial for shooting and
killing her arange
boyfriend she they took us to the scene
to look at where this had happened in
her apartment and she had an order of
protection against this person and he
was an
ex-marine and she had dead bolts on her
back door and she was so terrified of
him that she had had a dead bolt on her
bedroom
door and she still was didn't feel safe
and went out and purchased a
handgun and he came to her house
shattered the outside door as she ran to
the bedroom bolted that door and then he
came through that and she shot and
killed him if she had had to
wait if she had waited one more day to
go buy that gun she would not have been
in there I would not have been in a
court
case trying to find her guilty of murder
I would have been in a court
case trying to find this Marine for
murdering her cuz he was a big guy um
that bothered me a lot and this kind of
Bill would have prevent would prevent
her have prevented her from having the
handgun to protect
herself um background checks the
enhanced background checks the criminals
don't go by them I
a couple years ago you may have seen it
it might have been last year a guy in
Franklin killed his his wife and two of
his children and then himself on the gun
that he purchased illegally he was a
felon possession of a gun he bought it
from a felon in possession of a gun who
got it from a guy not far from my house
who had purchased it legally and once it
left his hands it passed through to two
more criminals before before um a
tragedy
and
having Universal background checks would
not have helped that at all you look at
most cases where criminals use a gun
you're going to find that they didn't
get it through a background check
somewhere and having or have a waiting
period for most people this this the
waiting periods IR relevant if I wanted
to buy one it wouldn't bother me too
much to wait a couple days because I've
got two or three guns already
but and criminals they don't care if
there's a background check they're not
going to they're not going to worry
about it my
nephew bless his soul had
um he tried driving his car into a
bridge AB butman didn't die my sister
had to coax him back to
healthy he jumped through their storm
door to try and kill himself
didn't didn't die she had to coax him
back to being healthy he finally got his
hands on some fenal and he died he never
people die people try to commit suicide
they don't always try to use a gun
they'd usually find a way if they're
serious about
it so waiting periods don't really
sir yeah
chair call J
[Music]
simin good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee
and I thank you for carving out some
time for
me made it here by the skin of my
teeth but sometimes that
happens House Bill 56 FN if an acted
will actually subvert Public
Safety seems to me the backers prefer a
high crime state in which case I think
they should move to
Massachusetts uh what I plan to do is to
provide you with some data cuz I wear
another hat Beyond being a federal
firearms liy I'm an international
economic
consultant so data have
meaning since
1985 the incidence of vion crime in
Massachusetts has at least been 1.8
times that of New
Hampshire that to me is significant at
no time over this nearly 40-year period
has the incidence of violent crime in
New Hampshire exceeded that in
Massachusetts so the conclusion that I
reach is that whatever we do and
whatever you and your predecessors have
done in the realm of Public Safety seems
to work and therefore House Bill 56 FN
in any variants should be voted in
expedient to
legislate some foundational
facts at end
2023 there were some 512 million
firearms in the United States I set
forth in my written testimony copies of
which I will of course provide the data
sources what's included and what's
excluded so the number could be 500
million or 495 it might be 525 but it's
close to half a billion Firearms key
Point anything so abundant and mainly
concealable cannot be controlled it's
for
doomed and what I say cannot be
controlled without police state measures
because there are many countries where
police state measures are in force and
the Civil population doesn't have
fact the Bill's backers seem to presume
that gun control underpins Public Safety
this is simply not
so at least
since
2001 Maine New Hampshire and
Vermont which for almost all of this
period had very few laws relating to
Firearms were the three safest States in
this Union safest states is measured by
the incidence of violent crime per
100,000 residents so it adjusts for the
differences in
population
pardon okay I will make just one more
quick point if I may Mr
chairman very quick in The Wider world
the downside to gun control isn't
fairness to firearm owners it is
genocide you simply cannot murder
hundreds of thousands or Millions unless
and until the targeted group and their
sympathizers are disarmed and thus those
who back gun
control willing or
not promote genocide I'll be happy to
take any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you sir and thank you
members of the
committee and with that I close the
public hearing on House Bill
56 we take a five minute recess before
hearing you text me which is awesome I
don't have my iPad so I can't open it on
I
don't
e
I'm hereby opening the public hearing on
talking
to when you finish could you just give
good morning once again thank you Mr
chairman and thank you committee so I'm
here to uh introduce House Bill 207 FN
for representative James Spain this be
uh this bill deals with the uh making
legal for persons over the age of 18 and
over blackjacks metallic Knuckles slung
thing one thing I'm sure of uh there's
not too many of us that are going to be
carrying around slung shots those slung
shots are legal in a fishing
industry it's it's rather a heavy and
cumbersome type
of weapon I guess you could call it that
uh I could take a scarf which I have
hanging in the other room which I needed
to wear today it was quite cold out
there and I could put a couple rocks in
there some used coffee pods that have
have wait to them after they've been
used and make a slung shot what what
this bill really does it's it's a
liberty bill it's a bill for those that
collect these types of things no one's
going to carry around a set of what used
to be called brass
knuckles or black Jacks without making
themselves known now the brass knuckles
yes you could hide those in your
pocket however we've seen in New York
City and a lot of these big cities these
knockout
contests where these punks will come up
behind somebody carrying a briefcase or
whatever and just coldcock them and
knock them to the ground they don't need
a set of brass knuckles to do that so
this again is for Liberty this is for
those that collect these types of unique
items I have a ceremonial Japanese
sword in my basement that was my
son's it's not the kind of thing I would
carry around but I think we need to look
at this as something that is not going
to be used for defensive purposes but
again it's a collectible I personally
would rather carry a firearm a pistol or
or a good knife versus any of these
things so keep that in mind again this
is a novelty thing and I would
appreciate your support on this Bill
thank you very much I'll take questions
if you have
them representative
Sher uh would you oppose a bill that uh
made it a violation or misdemeanor to
use any of these
items how do you mean
weapon uh thank you for the question but
I still don't understand what you're
saying to be used as a weapon you mean
aggressively against somebody yes you
you've testified that they're just
collectible so by by having a ban on
using them as a weapon uh it preserves
the right of people to collect these
things but not to use them well maybe
you and I will sit down and try and
develop some language on that thank
you see no further questions thank you
Manion thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Tom Manny I'm representing Hillsboro 1
pelum um I rise in support of uh 207 uh
I wholeheartedly believe everyone should
be armed for
self-defense but I understand that not
everyone is comfortable carrying a
firearm or maybe in a circumstance that
prohibits them from doing so as such we
should not be standing in the way of
these folks to have an effective means
to keep themselves
safe it has the added benefit of giving
a non-lethal alternative to defense from
an attacker which is admirable for those
that wish to have that option uh with
hb27 representative
Murray thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I'm not sure if
you'll know this but last
session um we tried we p i mean we
passed this to the house a couple times
um and I believe the Senate interim
studied it this past time do you know if
anything came out of that or if anything
has changed that would
change the outcome in the Senate I'm not
sure I mean I can ask my Senator I think
he was on that interim study I believe
thank you thank you for your
Hannah um thank you again I'll make this
very brief Joe Hannan um vice president
for second vice president for G of New
Hampshire uh we stand in favor of this
bill uh obviously uh these are not
Firearms under the legal definition but
they do fall under definition of arms um
and that is covered under the Second
Amendment
um as far as slung shots uh we heard it
was a maritime Tool uh it's like we're
you know it typically they would use a
you know knotted what they call a monkey
fist or a little knotted ball around a
piece of metal or um some other kind of
hard object and that'll be used to throw
lines um in Wars they would use similar
items for for combat like a mace with a
chain something in the end of the ball U
but someone could use a rock in a sock
if you had and I've seen people use that
and in different doing different
Outreach with homeless individuals and
things like that people will just put
something you heard you could just stick
anything a roll of quarters in a in a
sock or a in a T-shirt and that can be
used as a weapon uh we're Banning some
we're trying to we have something banned
that is you know I could make with
probably a dozen things in this room
very easily in about 10 seconds um so I
think it's very important that we uh do
pass this legislation and um repeal
something that really doesn't need to be
in the law whatsoever be happy to take
any
questions represent
Muse thank you for taking my question Dr
Hannon as a uh as a medical doctor um
can you give your opinion about the
difference between a blow struck to
someone's face with a fist
versus a blow struck to someone's face
with a slungshot breast Knuckles or a
blackjack well I was a foot and ankle
surgeon so I'll limit my answer to below
the knee uh I've treated gunshot wounds
I've treated people that have been you
know run over with lawnmowers been
thrown into campfires been physically
abused burned um I haven't seen anyone
hitting the foot or knee with a brass
knuckle and I couldn't do a
comparison I imagine it could be worse
but I could hit someone with a rock I I
think we all you know know that it's not
hard to hit someone with a hard object
so it's it's a very arbitrary and you
know uh if you look at the history of
the law it actually is it's a lot of U
you know U I would say
uh racist backgrounds I mean they would
go to certain minority groups and say
you they're doing this and we're going
to ban that as a as a whole they had uh
Saturday night specials were a ban on
firearms for the longest time because
that was what people realized that
people in poor communities were using uh
and they wanted to ban them so they just
banned Saturday Night Special so they're
trying to ban something that um they
they they thought they can control
certain populations with and I I don't
think that slung shots why everyone's
kind of confused why is slung shots in
there it's something that the working
Dock Workers poor fishermen that was
something that very poor working class
or workingclass people would use as
something that would just you know kind
of the equivalent of walking with your
car keys to your car you know should we
ban that it's what's readily a ailable
and I think Banning brass knuckles is no
dumber than Banning someone walking to
their car with car keys in their fist
like
this both would cause damage to the face
I
testimony anyone else wishing to testify
and spill is not testified seeing none I
hereby Clos public hearing we reconvene
at
12:00
e
and hereby open the public hearing on
House Bill
352 um relative toting possession of a
farm on a polling place and I introduce
I invite the prime sponsor and introdu
this
Bill thank you Mr chair um the prime
sponsor uh is in in the Judiciary
Committee and isn't available to uh
introduce the bill representative Horan
he's asked me to introduce the bill uh
in his place uh I have representative
Horgan's uh written testimony which I'll
distribute to the committee I also have
prepared testimony of my own which I
again uh just for the uh everyone that's
going to testify um due to the number of
cards we have signed up after the
representative speaks it'll be a
three-minute limit thank you again thank
you Mr chair thank you members of the
committee let me start by saying that in
this country no American should ever be
threatened with guns either explicitly
or implicitly while simply exercising
their right to vote intimidation
including intimidation by armed
civilians has long been a tool that some
people have used to prevent full
participation in US
democracy during and after
reconstruction guns were often used to
scare black voters away from the
polls that history of armed voter intim
intimidation is not a distance memory in
this country guns at the poles are a
Tinder boox near an open
flame in Manchester during the November
2020 election an armed man harassed
people holding signs for candidates in
the election AR the the electioneering
area uh outside three separate polling
places in Charlotte North Carolina an
armed man was arrested after a polling
supervisor asked him to leave a polling
place on Election Day and he returned in
Lane County Oregon armed individuals
approached people as they were dropping
off their ballots at a ballot
Dropbox Behavior like this not only puts
voters and election workers at risk it
also puts democracy itself at risk
HB 352 is a proactive attempt to make
our election safer for all of our
citizens this bill would prohibit
carrying a deadly weapon either out in
the open or concealed within 100 ft of a
polling place on days where federal
state or Municipal elections are taking
place 21 states in the District of
Columbia already explicitly prohibit
guns at polling places in some way but
unfortunately New Hampshire does not
under our current law state and local
authorities can't prevent people from
bringing guns into polling places even
those located inside school buildings as
an open carry state New Hampshire allows
gun owners to openly carry a loaded
firearm on public property without a
license or a permit since 2017 the state
has also allowed any lawful gun owner to
carry a concealed weapon without a
license with HP 352 we do have the power
to fix this and we have the
Constitutional authority to do so the
Supreme Court of the United States said
it best when they reasoned in Westbury
versus Sanders that quote no right is
more precious in a free country than
that of having a voice in the election
of those who make the laws under which
as good citizens we must live other
rights even the most basic are elusory
if the right to vote is
undermined however the fundamental right
to vote without fear of intimidation
vital to our democracy is endangered
when we allow deadly weapons to be
displayed as an implied threat to others
either inside or outside our polling
places in the heler decision Justice
Antonin Scalia wrote that while the
second amendment protects the right of
Law and abiding responsible citizens to
use arms in defense of Hearth and Home
he also wrote that nothing in our
opinion should be taken to cast doubt on
long-standing prohibitions on laws
forbidding the carrying of firearms in
sensitive places such as Schools and
Government buildings several States
including Georgia have already
interpreted sensitive places to include
polling places polling places are public
areas they are used to conduct elections
that are vital to our
democracy also worth pointing out is
that the same generation of people that
added the Second Amendment to the
Constitution also passed state laws
prohibiting bringing guns to the polls
for example the 1777
Delaware state constitution provided
that no person shall come armed to any
of to come to any polling place and no
muster of the militia shall be made on
that day it further provided that no
Battalion or company could come within a
mile of the polling place for 24 hours
before or after an election in order to
prevent violence or force from being
used at set elections that same year
Maryland passed an identical law New
York follow suit a decade later and more
States added similar laws during
Reconstruction and in the early 20th
century the bottom line is hb3 352 isn't
unconstitutional or an anti-gun law as
some people would like to frame it what
it is is a proter law that will lower
the risk of armed intimidation happening
in a place where it never should happen
I ask the committee to give this bill an
utapass recommendation and uh I will try
to take
questions thank you I obviously we've
we've seen this bill a few times over
the years um have you ever thought about
limiting it to the intentional display
of a firearm at a polling place versus
just saying no firearms are polling
places because if the object is to
prevent intimidation if you can't see it
you're not intimidating in in 2022 I
actually filed a bill that that did that
it limited to to concealed carry um uh
it or it actually allowed concealed
carry uh and prohibited open carry
within 100 ft of a polling place uh the
bill also uh amended our voter
intimidation statute uh so it was a it
approach you would be open to that that
concept I would definitely be open to
that concept thank you further questions
testimony representative Horgan uh he
introduced your bill of you're obviously
but um yes yes I'm I'm I'm the prime
sponsor and I thank represent Muse for
filling in with me I was afraid I
wouldn't be able to be here at all so
his he gave you a good rundown from what
I heard from the history of it my
history only goes back well 50 years or
a little bit a little bit more so
beginning with my written testimony here
um I've been attending elections for
long as I remember remember long before
I turned 18 in 1974 my parents voted in
every election they always made a point
of bringing me and my sisters to the
polling place with them so if you go
back as long as I remember that's you
know about 64 years or so and
um um I've seen seen a lot of things in
polling places over the years but I've
actually never seen a violent or
non-violent even a nonviolent crime
being committed at the polls so
U you know it's you know I've never seen
anything happen actually the election
officials couldn't have handle on their
own although certainly I'm worried that
something could happen the elections the
whole issue of the context of Elections
gets more and more controversial every
cycle you know we've seen we have seen
some pretty ugly things going on in
other states around
elections I'm I'm and I'm cognizant the
possibility of problems I'm glad that
polling places have a robust police
presence I'm here in Durham we usually
have at least two police officers who
actually are wearing Kevlar vest um
sometimes sometimes more so I think you
if there was some sort of violent
incident at the polling place I'm pretty
confident they could respond to it same
may be different in smaller towns with a
less you know with a smaller police
department but I
I from a security P standpoint I don't
think there's like any anything that's
held by having random uh you know random
voters pulling out their personal
firearms and you know responding to a
perceived threat so I mean I met the
police officers they're there not just
for deterring Crime they're an integral
part of the vote counting process like
law
enforcement they have the job of of
making sure the deliver materials are
delivered at the secretary's of State's
office after they're all counted and
filed and of course especially if have a
high turnout election they have to be
there to direct
bill in terms of a open intentional your
you mentioned your session about
intentional open caring I I mean I think
that's I think trying to parse whether
it's intentional or not if if somebody
if somebody sees a gun regardless if
it's intentional or unintentional their
response you know is is going to be the
same anyway and
um and uh I mean
would and um so anyway so I've never
it's very rare to see voters open caring
at the Ponting place I think it's a good
thing they don't open carry um
especially if it's someone I don't know
I don't don't necessarily know if I can
trust the person who's open carrying you
know I don't always know
like you know I don't always know like
who's carrying gun who I trust to only
use it if needed or who's just you know
you know who might just pull it out for
some bad reason and it's so it's um
anyways it's uh this bill makes it as
simple as possible for gun owners and
non gun owners alike by banning guns and
other deadly weapons within 100 ft of
the Ping Place using the commonly aced
meeting of the word phrase polling place
um so that's appears in many laws that's
clearly understood to be where the
election activities are taking place um
I know previous bills we sometimes had
issues like um how do I know where the
polling place is like if it's on there's
um like
there's there's like there's an issue
with a uh School in a town I think
believe it's believe it's haal where the
school property AB buts a common duck
hunting stuff there's much concerned
about somehow somebody who's hunting
ducks wandering on the wrong side of the
property line and being unknowingly
being at the Bing place but um and um we
do make exceptions here for uh who do I
see
exactly there's there's exceptions for
the for the polling place for law
enforcement um and also for Here We Go
law enforcement officials on duty so
obviously which we already have the uh
you like the police officers in Durham
um they have their service weapons uh
with them uniformed Law Enforcement
Officers while they're exercising their
right to vote um that was inspired
especially by our newly elected County
Sheriff Katherine bone who um well she
voted in civilian clo uh this year she
was not yet the sheriff but she was a
police officer in another jurisdiction
and so she would often stop by her way
to work so that's perfectly appropriate
to wear her whole uniform including the
service revolver which
99.99% of the time is mostly just there
as part of the uniform you know police
officers uh routinely police officers uh
they're always ready to fire the service
revolvers but it's something they avoid
doing unless absolutely necessary so um
and also non-uniform law enforcement
officers who are concealed carrying
their own their service weapons so
that's um just I admit that applies only
to you know law enforcement officers who
you know um
are not wearing the uniforms at the time
so they can still you know especially
you know they may be like a detective or
something like that where they you know
they they have to have the service
weapon you know it's part of their
outfit but they're not openly displaying
it while they're on duty and um also you
can secure your unloaded firearm in a
motor vehicle while at the poing place
that does mean you have to unload the
firearm you do have to lock it up but
you can park it at the poing place even
if your even if that sometimes happens
your parking space is within the 100t
foot radius so that's um and finally I
just added a little thing to the
previous bill that we had uh last year
which is making that making your uh
making adding another reason why you can
get an absentee ballot so we added we
added a thing quote I am willing or
unwilling to comply with the prohibition
of firearms at ping places in RSA
15928 so that's uh that's not strictly
speaking that's not necessary we have a
very permissive absentee voting laws
anyway but and um I don't know how many
people would check it off but like if
you absolutely you know cannot stand to
lock your gun in the car if you
absolutely can't stand to leave it at
home if you
absolutely can't bear to be without it
for the few minutes it takes to check in
at the check in with the uh ballot
officials and fill out your B if you
absolutely can't stand that if you just
either can't bear it because you don't
think it's safe you just can't bear you
just can't bear to not be wearing your
gun you can get an absentee ballot and
mail it in so that um I'm just trying to
avoid disenfranchising anybody who wants
to vote even you know just I don't want
to disenfranchise gun owners from from
from voting so that's uh so that's
that's my bill and um you know you've
already heard about from refin Muse so
he's you've got like two pretty good
arguments in favor of it
and I see at least one hand raised so
perhaps I'll be answering a
question um representative
Sher uh representative Horgan would you
be amenable to a friendly Amendment to
the bill that replaced the word carry
with openly display um sure yes I me I
mean that's up to that's up to you I
mean I I I mean I'm not not a big fan of
these things where like with our I
didn't vote for the house rule where we
had you know where we say you're not
we're supposed to be if we're carrying
we're supposed to be concealed caring
now push an intention or unintentional
but I I I certainly be happy with I
would consider a friendly Amendment
representative and certainly uh if that
that gets more votes for it I'm
you see no more questions thank you
thank you the chair calls The Honorable
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Tom
Manion I'm representing Hillsboro 1 uh
the town of pelum uh I'm testifying in
opposition of HB 352 uh in an age of
increasing divisiveness especially
centered around politics it's important
that every person be capable of
Defending themselves should the need
arise and every person's first line of
defense is themselves we should not have
to choose between exe exercising our
right to vote and our right to
self-defense on Election Day I'm also
not supportive of the expanding the
reasons for absentee voting when I think
the better solution is just leave things
the way they are with that I ask the
members of the committee I'm
representative Donald McFarland from
Orange and I thank you for your time the
testimony represents My Views and most
importantly the views and interests of
my constituents uh in graft 18 the
testimony is not made on behalf of any
private employer nor should be construed
to represent the views of any of my
employers elections are the Cornerstone
of our democracy and this
unconstitutional Bill House Bill 352 act
to prohibit people from traditional
in-person participation in the voting
process to my honorable colleague from
Durham's assertion that he does not seek
to disenfranchise voters nevertheless
this is exactly what this bill achieves
yes there is a provision for absentee
ballots and I'll get to
that the the bill as written may work in
his mind I would suggest not for voters
it most certainly does not work for
election workers like the Selectmen the
ballot clerks the supervisors of the
checklist candidates holding sign
near the polling place or wishing to use
the restroom and so
forth my colleague from Durham I didn't
hear all of his testimony I was still in
in judiciary next door but I heard the
end of his testimony he expressed
concern specifically around open carry
and I dare say he has read his own bill
and he knows perfectly well that this
bill applies equally to concealed carry
and would be objectionable in either
form uh and as I said earlier it is
unconstitutional uh it is objectionable
to to part one uh both article 2A and
article 11 uh and I think that um when
you consider this you need to also
consider the election law impact this
essentially is a
backdoor bill that turns absente ballots
into early voting I would recommend
strongly that this committee recommend
itl on the bill and that this committee
recommend that this bill be referred to
the house election law committee thank
you
gon thank you Mr chair honorable
committee uh for record representative
Henry gon philbo 29th
District so once again we are talking
about violating somebody's an eliable
right in order to allow them to exercise
another right when we create areas where
people are not allowed to carry their
firearms we are creating areas of
victims where shootings have happened
and license to carry has been allowed
the shooting duration extremity and
number of casualties has been
significantly reduced and this is on
record throughout the United States
where mass shootings have had the most
impact is in places where Firearms are
restricted where the Constitution has
not been followed and where the rights
of the people have been violated by
their own government now I heard a uh I
heard a suggestion to secure a firearm
in a
car the fastest loss of firearms is a
smash and grab from a vehicle there are
police officers that have lost their
service weapons in a smash and grab from
a vehicle locking your vehicle in a car
loaded or unloaded is not securing a
firearm on a personage or in a safe or
in a domicile it is putting it in a
mobile place that you can smash into
very easily that is not safe securing of
a firearm no matter where you are school
grounds are otherwise polling station or
otherwise so I would sub I would submit
to you that if you are responsible to
carry a firearm you should not be H uh
have to store it in a place that is
unsecure but in final I will also say
that this is simply a violation of New
Hampshire state constitution and of the
United States con Constitution and of
the rights of the people that your job
is to protect thank you for your
time thank you for your
testimony the chair calls representative
SEL
ORS thank you again Mr chairman and
committee feel like you've seen me here
before but I'm glad you got to see me
again so having worked for the
Department of Defense Bae system
some bigger
corporations I have worked in big cities
around the world I'll let you know that
uh I have been assaulted several times
in these cities uh including being
punched in the face and two different
occasions and being robbed and uh
wishing I had a firearm anytime your
firearm is taken away from you whether
it's put in a car or put somewhere else
and it's not on your body uh you are you
are in a position where someone can take
advantage of you and I did not
appreciate the fact of uh going home at
the end of the day with a a black eye
and had I had a weapon on me which I
could not carry in places like New York
City or a couple of the other cities
I've been in uh the outcome would have
been different and I would have still
had uh the cash in my pocket at the end
of the day so with that I'm open for uh
any
questions thank you for your testimon
thank
schover hello my name is Kathleen Slover
I'm um from Portsmith New Hampshire and
I'm speaking on behalf of myself please
vote a to pass on HB 352 I just want to
tell you something that happened to me
recently to illustrate the importance of
prohibiting Firearms at a polling
place um a couple of weeks ago uh in
Portsmith um we held a people's March
and I arrived a half hour early to the
South Church in Portsmith I was one of
the many organizers my son dropped me
off in front of the church and said Mom
there are guys with
guns he saw them before I did I quickly
said oh oh they're they're probably
police and he knew better than me he
said no they're not one was head to toe
black but not a stitch of Pat or patch
identifying him as Portsmouth Police the
other wore a t-shirt with the FW and a
mask I took a deep breath and with a pit
in my stomach I exited the car brushed
past the armed men and entered the
church already the band was playing and
many people were holding signs and
marching and dancing in place safety and
numbers I thought by the time the event
started Portsmouth Police had arrived
uh my son actually came back with my
husband and they stayed on the sidewalk
to I guess make sure everything was okay
and they were the last to enter the
church and they said the um the armed
men did not enter the church there was
no question that these men were there to
intimidate and Bully I was worried and
concerned for all the people that I
personally invited to this event I
encouraged them to raise their voice
only for them to be greeted with armed
protesters I don't tell this story to
make people panic or to clutch my pearls
I tell it to illustrate that people do
use their guns to intimidate to scare
and to attempt to silence and this
happened in one of the safest states in
the country and one of the safest cities
just a few weeks ago according to a
survey of local election officials
across the US 38% report experiencing
threats harassment or abuse and 54
concern 54% are concerned about the
safety of their colleagues and according
to one election official here in New
York New Hampshire threats and
harassment are deterrent to Recruitment
and the presence of firearms creates a
potentially serious deterrent to the
efficiency and reliability of pull work
I am not an expert on the Constitution
but I do know that the right to bear
arms the right to vote and the right to
free speech must and should coexist with
laws governing all of them in New
Hampshire at a polling place the law
requires a visible and audible
electioneering Zone which protects
freedom of speech but the law also
requires a no election nearing zone so
voters can vote without interruption
interference or safety concerns this
creates a safe environment in which
Granite Staters can exercise their right
to vote this should include prohibiting
Firearms no one is taking away someone's
right to have a firearm just a limit on
one day in one place where if allowed
Firearms can be used to scare intimidate
and threaten and no one should feel that
way while exercising their right to vote
testimony the chair recognizes The
Stone good
afternoon I'm Jonathan Stone from
clamont New Hampshire and uh I rise in
opposition of House Bill 352 very simply
why would any citizen have to give up
one right to exercise another right it
seems this bill is based mostly on
feelings and not facts and did any law
enforcement ask for this legislation be
pushed at this level I would recommend
it Ling this bill I looked at some of
the quick numbers that representative
Muse comes out with and I believe the
numbers are actually 18 states plus DC
prohibit them explicitly there's partial
restrictions in seven states and uh 25
of our states has zero restrictions on
fire in polling places uh I spoke with
the deputy chief of the clont police
department yesterday in reference to any
issues we've had during our election
Cycles which I've partaken in about
let's say since 2017 I've been at every
election in the city of clamon and also
throughout Sullivan County for various
positions I've ran for and there's never
really been a significant issue with
firearms that I've ever been noted and I
checked with the clerks quite often to
ask if there's any problems and I see
this bill as just being one that's
unnecessary I see a segment of the bill
that says even licensed uh if you want
to talk about licensing and federal law
most people are unaware that under the
safe uh school zone act which is the gun
free zone if you're a license invented
in your home state you're Exempted from
them school zones that's anybody can
research under the federal code we need
to stop looking at uh feelings of
individuals when it comes to giving up
constitutional rights I see this bill is
just problematic overall and I'd like to
thank you for your time if you have any
questions I'll take
them thank you just um real quick to
expand on the point you just made so
right now in New Hampshire if you go to
a polling place and it's in a school and
you do not have a license to carry are
you not in violation of federal law
because the state of New Hampshire
elected to be a constitutional carry
state it's my understanding that the US
attorney's office at the time had said
there'd be no prosecutions under it
unless there was a companion case of
criminal activi such as drug trafficking
for which the real intent of the gun
free zone is is drug trafficking is an
enhanced penalty uh if you have a
license it's clearly an exemption under
you that's all thank you thank you uh
okay this interest this legislation has
an interesting twist in that it violates
not only one protected right but two two
infringements on our rights for the
price of one bill if you want to
practice your fundamental human right to
self-defense on Election Day according
to the bill you are not allowed to if
you want to practice your protected
right to vote you aren't allowed to
practice your protected fundamental
human right to self-defense
I can't make it make sense and after
hearing the sponsor speak he can't even
make it make sense and I don't care
about the voting via absentee ballot
provision these are the same people who
support that support this legislation
who also claim that out of state college
students have to vote in New Hampshire
because properly voting via absentee
ballot in their permanent resident home
States is just too difficult and an
infringement on their voting rights this
bill enables predatory Criminal to more
easily seek out their prey knowing
law-abiding citizens will obey this
ridiculous gun control law this bill
makes graned Staters less safe
especially women who are carrying due to
specific violent threats against their
lives there's no problem this bill is
trying to solve and it's ironic and
amusing and slightly insane that
everyone who's bringing up gun control
laws in other states that we should
follow those States they're bringing up
states that are less safe than New
Hampshire New Hampshire is consistently
the safest state in the country why we
want to be less safe like all these
other states is beyond me and we will
still be that safe unless we put gun
controls laws like this into place
because they will make us less safe
please vote inexpedient to legislate on
this
good afternoon um my name is jeie loot
um I am
um wearing many hats today but um I'm
here primarily as a concerned election
official I am currently a supervisor of
the checklist in Amherst actually one of
my um colleagues is here as well uh
there are three of us in every town
hopefully you all understand that um and
our job is to um on Election Day we are
there for 17 hours um in at least in in
Amherst and we uh register folks to vote
all day and um at the end of the night
we count our checklist to make sure that
it matches the um the voter machines
um I it's very important that I need to
ensure um the voter that they are um
casting their vote in a safe place um
currently uh with the situation of
allowing guns um into our elections on
um polling day um it provides
intimidation and a threat to individual
voting
rights um you'll be interested to know
that um the Secretary of State's office
has trained us um um recently because of
the um uh increased volatility in
politics and elections and um um
officials have been threatened uh
they've trained us um at um elections to
try to figure out ways to lower the
temperature so that's that never
happened before it's only happened in
say the last five years that um we've
been alerted to the fact that we need to
um arm ourselves uh with words um to try
to keep people from becoming volatile um
we have power because we um determine
whether someone um has the right
credentials to vote in our in our town
um the legislature has just made it more
difficult because um they've taken away
affidavits and now all documents have to
be provided or we turn you away uh which
to me sets up a situation where someone
could be angry and possibly um use a
weapon against me or any other election
official um I support this bill HB uh
352 because it supports the right of
citizens to cast their ballot in a safe
place ensuring that citizens are safely
casting a vote supersedes the right to
carry a gun into the
blanger hello again rayel Lander from
Tilton I'm against this bill one of the
things that people are always zeroing in
on is is proposing that there's some
crazy people out there are going to go
into a polling place and shoot it up I
don't think there are many many people
there that are thinking about that I'm
not thinking about that I have to get to
the polling place I'm getting older
every day I don't run as fast as I could
I'm less capable and to tell me I can't
go vote I can't bring my gun to where
I'm going to vote so that I'm safe on my
way there and on my way home and in the
parking lot which in my town is not very
far from the bike PA which as you know
has become a hangout for people to do
and you need to everyone needs to be
safe wherever they go and in traveling
to and from polling places is one of the
places you should be allowed to be safe
and if I can't bring my firearm there
and I live in a town where I have to
walk past some of these places you're
taking away my right to be safe getting
there to vote so I might some people
might not want to go because they no
longer feel safe getting there um I was
glad someone mentioned that federal law
says a person really should needs to
have a state permit to go onto school
grounds although no one has been
prosecuted for walking by or being
within 1,000
feet it only going to take one case for
some federal Marshal to know that
doesn't like you or thought you
were doing something wrong to write you
up and arrest you for having a firearm
so it's good to have a permit if you're
going to go on school grounds but it's
advertised that you don't need one
because we're a constitutional carry
state and I don't think that's true I
think you could get prosecuted very
easily for not having the permit
um I just um
I just think that you know it's safer
the other thing and New Hampshire is one
of the safest states why because no one
knows who's carrying a firearm who isn't
if they think that some of the pole
workers might be carrying
firearms um you know to help keep
themselves safe that just makes it a a
better thing to have that everyone can
keep themselves safe by arming
themselves concealed would be better I
wouldn't never open carry but some
people like that as a deterrent um the
police certainly do they open carry as a
deterrent um I would hope you would vote
against this bill so that we can all be
safe wherever we
hello again I just wanted to um start
off with a quote from the great
philosopher John Loch who said
self-defense is a part of the laws of
nature nor can it be denied the
community nor even against the king
himself last year I became a Citizen and
I was very proud to vote in my first
primary and federal election and
honestly sometimes I have to pinch
myself to remember this is not a dream I
am a citizen of the greatest nation on
Earth and I live in arguably the
greatest state in the nation the Live
Free or Die state which was the first to
recognize and protect those natural laws
with its robust Constitution that uh led
the way and it
um I find it a little bit sad and
alarming that bills like this come up to
disarm me when I'm exercising my right
to vote and still having to retain my
natural right to
self-defense um I think it's
unconstitutional and cruel to deny me
that right to self-defense
um I think gun-free zones are cruel as
well um I'm quite sure that fish in a
barrel feel very very safe but if you
think about it you know they're
not uh a bill like this in my opinion
would increase um the chance if any of
uh violent incidents at a poing place by
essentially putting a metaphorical neon
sign saying unarmed citizens
inside uh I would suggest a reverse
of this bill to have a condition made
for um the paranoid Among Us who would
like to stay home While others are
exercising their natural right that they
should be able to uh vote by absentee so
that um they feel safe and the rest of
us live free and so I would ask you to
um to object to this bill on those on
those accounts thank you thank you for
your
Davis honorable members of the committee
my name is Justin Davis I serve as a New
Hampshire state director and I'm a New
Hampshire resident a lot of this been
covered already I know it's going to be
a long day so I'll try to make this
brief um as as previously mentioned um
this would create soft several soft
several hundred soft targets throughout
New Hampshire uh with no mandate for
protection from police from mag Pond
from mag uh from mags to make sure that
there's nobody coming in uh with
Firearms if they're supposed to be
so-called gun-free zones um as we've
seen since 1950 from the crime
prevention center 94% of mass shootings
have happened in gun-free zones so we're
making a very dangerous scenario for
people who are looking to vote on
Election Day and I've heard a lot about
talk about intimidation and and saying
that folks who uh carry firearms will
intimidate folks who don't well we're
not thinking about the pole workers who
carry firearms because they want they
want to feel comfortable right maybe
they feel intimidated to go out to vote
or be a pole worker without their
firearm what about individuals who are
sexual assault survivors who don't feel
comfortable leaving their home without
their firearm and now they're forced to
use an absentee voting system which they
may not feel comfortable with as we've
seen over the last several years a lot
of people have addressed concerns about
the absente voting system um whether
whether those are true or not that's not
for me to to say but that uh that
concern does exist so uh the NRA
strongly supports your uh or urges you
to vote against this measure and I'm
happy to take any questions you may
have seeing none thank you for
Hannon good afternoon uh Joe Hannon gers
of New Hampshire again um we're
obviously in opposition to this bill 352
we'd ask you to itl it um this is a
Firearms owner disenfranchisement bill
this is basically saying that you know
you're not welcome here uh they have a
workaround which is great and I think
it's nice that they've tried to include
Firearms owners in a protected class of
people that are considered uh to be
unable to vote for religious reasons
disability reasons or employment
obligations so I don't know if that was
the implication but it's an interesting
little tidbit that was put in there and
um anyway I just thought I'd mention
that um also loading and unloading a
firearm in a in a parking lot or vehicle
is an inherently more risky Behavior
than keeping it holstered and walking in
with it um accidents can happen and I
think that the worst place to do that is
in a crowded area like a school parking
lot or a municipal building's parking
lot somewhere uh we've heard that it's
also a danger that people can get be
more likely to have a firearm stolen um
during those situations I had a firearm
stolen from a vehicle many years ago uh
in Florida person that stole it was
felon sold it to another known felon
luckily they arrested him contacted me
and were able to to fix the situation he
spent 5 years in jail because it was a
mandatory minimum uh when he was
released from jail they let me know that
he was out just because I may be
concerned uh that someone I had put in
jail for 5 years might not be happy with
me um if this passed he'd know that I
can go to the polls one day and I'd be a
good Target that day but anyway this is
also a ban on workers from being able to
defend themselves so we heard pole
workers talking about it um there is
often a police officer or at different
polling places and I understand that
people think that's enough of a
deterrent um it may be in some instances
to deter some people from committing
crimes but um they may not always be
there they may be the first person shot
who was the second person shot I don't
want to be that second person um and the
other thing this bill does is it simply
intends to make the presence of a
firearm whether visible or not an actual
threat or a crime it's not it's a legal
activity no one has hurt anybody else if
someone is threatening menacing or
trying to prevent someone from voting
those are all crimes and they're all
enforceable in New Hampshire and I don't
believe anyone has had uh any major
difficulty getting those those laws
enforced um almost
done um this does make it a misdemeanor
to do so uh if someone is willing to
commit a felony in all these other
instances I don't see how this
misdemeanor is going to stop them from
uh committing felonies or committing
severe VI some major violence and other
issues uh when you sign the form or you
check off the box to get your absentee
ballot to be eligible says I'm
unwilling or unable to comply with the
prohibition of firearms at polling
places so you're basically admitting I'm
a problem I can't do this that may not
be a problem with the current government
even the people in you know future
governments but what if there's a future
totalitarian government or regime that
finds that people who checked that box
may be people they don't like very much
now you're on an enemy list it becomes a
registration problem um with people that
are in these special categories
um anyway people are innocent till
proven guilty and this is basically
making criminals out of people who have
not committed a crime and I ask you to
please itl this
Bill thank you for your
testimony happy to take any or none no
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the
committee my name is Jay simkin I reside
in Nash New Hampshire I've been a
federal firearms license for something
over 40
years I'm also an international economic
consultant so data have meaning
in the
data that I submitted with my testimony
on House Bill 56 that has been
heard I pointed out and I repeat here
for the sake of good order that since
2015 the incidence of violent crime in
New Hampshire has declined year after
year even during the pandemic when the
incidents of violent crime Rose in many
states it continued to fall here it
continued to fall even after we
eliminated compulsory lure for concealed
carry so there is something different
about New Hampshire relative to other
states and that makes a little less
relevant at very least what occurs in
other states New Hampshire based on 22
2022 data published by the FBI is the
second safest state in the Union Maine
has been the safest state in the Union
at least since
2001 that doesn't show any signs of
changing so if there is a problem with
pulling Place security the proper
response is for this great house to
legislate that security be provided for
polling
places the fact that no violent
act has occurred at a polling place
isn't probative but it's indicative that
it's not likely but the likelihood isn't
zero it's low so if you and your
colleagues in this great house believe
that there is a real risk of violence at
polling places appropriate money for
towns and cities to higher security one
other point
if you had before you an official of the
US Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco firearms
and explosives I'm pretty confident
about 99% so that they would strongly
recommend against leaving firearms in
vehicles vehicles are a major
source of firearms for
criminals most of you have probably read
that cars have been sto that had infants
in the back seat and the thief intent on
making off with the vehicle didn't
notice the
child that alone should be warning
sufficient that encouraging folks to
leave firearms and vehicles is a really
bad idea and simply should not be done
thank you Mr simin I'm happy to take any
questions looks like you're all set
thank you thank you madam chairwoman and
members of the committee be
well is there anybody else here wishing
to testify on House Bill
hearing we will Recon we will reconvene
1:30
e
I'm opening the public he on Hospital 56
and invite the prime sponsor to
Bill thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee happy to be here this
afternoon to present this bill uh this
will be one of several of my bills that
due to some Nuance probably wound up in
maybe the second or third most
appropriate committee however I don't
doubt your qualifications to hear it and
I hope you'll come away in agreement
with the purpose of this bill so while
at first glance this appears to be a
simple Firearms nullification bill it is
not in fact that uh it's much more than
that despite the misleading title you
will not find reference to the National
Firearms Act anywhere in this bill
that's because this bill is not about
the NFA nor is it really about
nullification and interposition now
don't get me wrong I like James Madison
am a major proponent of the doctrine of
nullification and interposition however
this bill is designed from top to bottom
to elicit a specific legal challenge in
the federal courts by drawing a federal
lawsuit under the supremacy
clause I make this challenge because I
believe for the first time in many
generations
the present composition of the Supreme
Court might be such that they have the
guts to overturn the worst decision in
the history of the United
States the Commerce Clause of the United
States Constitution reads to regulate
commerce with foreign Nations and among
the several States and with the Indian
tribes this is the provision that
authorizes the federal government to
regulate
commerce initially this Clause was
interpreted properly and narrowly to
suggest that the federal government had
the authority to regulate interstate
commerce as trade between states in the
time since the federal Judiciary has
repeatedly expanded on this
interpretation and seized Powers not
delegated to it under the
Constitution while initially a measure
to break down trade barriers such as the
levying of tariffs by one State against
another state in a protectionist manner
this expansive understanding over the
centuries has come
to provide the federal government with
the authority to tell a farmer within
our state that he cannot grow more than
a certain amount of grain on his own
land for his own personal consumption
and in support of his own
livestock this is the result of a series
of Supreme Court opinions reminiscent of
Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon where if you
can establish L any link no matter how
tenuous to trade between states then
Congress can regulate it this is not an
exaggeration this was the exact subject
of the lawsuit wicker versus filburn of
1942 where the federal government shut
down the operations of a private farmer
and land owner growing wheat on his own
land for his own personal
use they established this authority to
regulate under the following leaps of
logic wheat grown privately for use on
someone's own land means that the same
amount of
wheat which would otherwise be purchased
at Market no longer has to be
purchased which has some immeasurable
effect on the economy of Wheat by
reducing Demand on the market and the
wheat Market is a national Market
existing between states and therefore
this private activity of growing weed on
your own land for your own use can be
regulated under the Commerce
Clause under this awful phenomenological
approach quite literally anything at all
could be regulated by the federal
government under the the Commerce Clause
in the modern world that would give the
authority over things such as 3D
printing at home or knitting a child
your hat a hat for your own child
because doing so affects the marketplace
broadly by reducing ing
demand this is not what the founders
intended we can know this firmly as they
use the word among the states to
represent interstate commerce not the
word within the states which would have
given them the authority to regulate
commerce within a
state this Supreme Court decision was
perhaps the most consequential and
terrible overreach in all of American
History this decision robbed the states
of sovereignty and their elected
representatives that would be us of the
power to craft just laws regulating or
deregulating Commerce within their own
borders it was a death below to the
already wounded concept of the United
States as a federal republic and serve
to significantly transition our form of
government toward a progressive
democracy so this bill is not really
about Firearms at heart this bill is
about giving our current courts another
bite at this apple and an opportunity to
write a rather large historical wrong
should this be successful and result in
an overturning of wicker or a narrowing
of the interpretation of the Commerce
Clause the results for this and every
other state in the Union would be so
meaningful for
federalism it would go a long way toward
restoring the founding vision of America
as a Federation of
republics it would allow economic
activity to
Boom it would put our Troublesome
Federal bureaucracy back in a box such
that the average New Hampshire citizen
doesn't have to worry about their
quirkiness because it just doesn't
affect them that
much and with that I'm happy to take
questions thank you are you aware of any
other cases that are in the pipeline
that are going to challenge that
ruling presently I'm not aware of any
challenges to the Commerce Clause that
are pending okay and can you explain how
this bill if enacted would trigger such
a lawsuit yes so what it almost
certainly would happen because this
specifically seeks to exempt um certain
Manufacturing in the state of New
Hampshire from federal oversight this
would trigger a lawsuit against the
state by the federal government under
the supremacy clause which opens the
door to the state and under the current
um circumstances in America I believe we
would be joined by many other states in
arguing for a restricting of the
definition of uh the Commerce Clause it
do you feel that this subject matter I
mean the the Supreme Court could
theoretically take it and also very
narrowly decid it just on the Firearms
aspect do you think this is Broad enough
to trigger the whole Commerce Clause um
decision that's a very good question I I
can't speculate as to what the ultimate
outcome would be I would be happy to see
a large change I would also be happy to
see a small change that could represent
an opening to Future further changes
thank
you yes uh representative lell thank you
for taking my question um so if if I get
the gist of the bill correctly this
would
exempt firearms made within the state of
New Hampshire from the National Firearms
Act is that
correct uh kind of yes it's a little
more expansive than that so it actually
it doesn't speak strictly to the
National Firearms Act it speaks to all
authority that the federal government
claims to regulate um Firearms
manufacturing under the Commerce Clause
which would effectively be all federal
firearms regulations follow up Mr
chairman MH the National Firearms Act
was put in place during the Depression
to prohibit gangsters from having
machine
guns um that was the original impetus
for the National Firearms Act if this
bill were to pass and become law would
machine guns be legal in the state of
New
Hampshire well that that would be the
question for the courts to establish
once the um actual lawsuit occurred and
the arguments were to happen uh but I
would I would actually note that though
it's not currently legal gangsters all
over this country already have machine
guns they put switches on their Glocks
and they they shoot up cities all over
the
place thank you and is it not true that
if you happen to be a very rich citizen
you can buy a machine gun now you indeed
can it's uh it's very costly and it
requires a bit of a weight and
fingerprinting and all kinds of other
stuff but yes you can in fact purchase a
machine gun or a suppressor or a short
barrel rifle or any of the above thank
you see no further questions thank you
thank
you um the shair recognizes
representative
Manu thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh for the record I'm Tom
Manion representing Hillsboro one pelum
I'm testifying in support of HB 381 as
the prime sponsor explained very
eloquently uh we're in a great position
to continue to challenge bad Supreme
Court precedents we've overturned
Chevron reigning in Bure bureaucratic
overregulation we've overturned row
returning one of the most cont uh
contentious issues to States where
people can move to and from states to
live according to their beliefs now is
the time to challenge the bad president
of wicker V filburn that is directly
responsible for the erosion of the 10th
Amendment and the consolidation of power
in DC
at face value the bill continues
promoting New Hampshire as the
friendliest for gun ownership and
entices new manufacturing job creators
to move here but it also serves as a
vehicle for the inevitable Court
challenge that will both question bad
provisions of the National Firearms Act
and the precedent of wicker I ask the
committee post U vote OTP on HB
381 thank you for your testimony thank
you is anyone else wishing to testify on
this bill who hasn't done so
saying not I close the public do you
want to testify you need to fill out a
pink card please just grab the card and
testify thank you Mr chair members of
the committee my name is MIL myit I'm
from Pittsfield New Hampshire I
represent myself here's testify in favor
of this bill specifically as it regards
sound suppressors you can um there's all
sorts of you can say what you will about
machine guns short bar barreled
rifles sound suppressors on the other
hand
are the
um sound suppressors are presently very
rare in throughout the United States
including New Hampshire because of the
amount of paperwork it
takes I believe that almost every
firearm ought to have have a sound
suppressor this status quo in fact
enables the prolifer ation of one of
those evils that General Stark told us
was greater than
death how do I know about this well I
wasn't into guns as a child at the age
of five I took up the piano turns out
when you do that your sense of hearing
develops a little bit better I have
perfect
pitch wasn't until 2019 though that I
started to uh want to put my Farm's
enthusiasm into practice with local
Friendly neighborhood indoor gun range
took an NRA basic pistol class went back
weekends then in the summer of 2020 I
started to realize that this this right
to keep and bear arms carries with it a
responsibility to do so went back to
that same facility one more
time in that moment after I cut the
ignition but before I pulled the door
handle I heard peace and
quiet that was the last time I ever did
so that's where my story
ends the one thing you still have
control over is how many other stories
throughout New Hampshire are you going
to let end the same way before you pass
this bill into law how do you take
questions so is it your testimony to the
committee today that your hearing was
damaged due to being exposed to a
discharging of a firearm precisely okay
and that had suppressors been used they
would not have been were you were you
not wearing hearing protection at the
time I was wearing hearing protection
and it's still yes because your hearing
was
enhanced I believe so thank you for your
testimony any questions see none thank
you so anyone else wish should testify
seeing none I close the public
pm
okay
e
I open the public hearing on House Bill
506 invite the prime sponsor to or a
thank you Mr chair members of Criminal
Justice it's nice to be
back um I was asked to file this bill by
a constituent this is a bill from last
year if you remember most of you
remember House Bill
um that bill passed through this
committee uh I think it was
19-0 uh went out of Finance 25 to0 and
it passed the house it got hung up in
the Senate they laid it on the table and
ended up killing it in October of last
year um the version of the bill you see
now was the latest version of it there
was some issues with a shell in a May
and some of the language that was
changed to May so this bill is
essentially the same bill that we had
here last year what this bill does is it
allows the return of property taken by
um court order for either bail
conditions or restraining order or any
other court order that um requires the
police to take your
Firearms the issue with this is once
that order has been vacated people have
find themselves waiting you know weeks
months maybe several months to get their
property back so that person once that
order is vacated they can go buy a
firearm but they can't get their
property back so this puts limits on it
for the court to act on it um so that
this property can be returned
um expeditiously so um that's basically
what the bill
does uh if you have any questions I'll
try to answer them however there are
people that going to speak behind me
that might be better served at answering
those
questions thank you if I
recall there was also an
issue where people had to actually bring
a court case a separate court case to
get their property back it wasn't being
handled within the is that is that the
case yeah I believe they had to request
a hearing and then the court would set
up a hearing date that could be a month
two months three months out and they
have to go in and and have a a court
hearing in order to get their property
returned that should essentially be
returned once the order the first order
was vacated and if they had been
assigned councel in their case let's say
a defense Council because it was an
assault case and they won the assault
case that Council wouldn't represent
them to get their property back they had
to go out and get another attorney is
that correct that's how I believe it yes
okay thank you representative
share what were the problems in the
Senate it was laid on the table and I
don't know what the actual problem was I
think they were hanging on to it and uh
to kind of hold it during Committee of
conference time and nothing it wasn't
acted on so come October they it it got
it thank you representative lell
thank you for taking my question
um if this bill was enacted into law how
would it work you say now it's it's drug
out there's a lot of uh judicial uh
regar rooll and so forth so how would
this
work so this is a question probably
better suited for someone who's going to
speak after me but this gives specific
time time frames that that the process
has to be completed by um it's not just
you request a hearing and the court will
schedule the hearing when they have time
and we've had people testify that it
could take upwards of three months this
here has specific time frames uh that
the court has to schedule and have this
property returned by so it gives
frames thank
you representative rhods
thank you Mr chairman U thank you
representative man just a quick question
um on L 17 where it says whether written
or oral the court shall request is there
would there be something like to fill
out so it's just not so it's not just
hearsay it says written or oral so I I'm
not sure if that what what would be the
case
there okay thank I would assume that if
the the the person during the hearing
made the request that would count or it
would be through a motion um written by
their
attorney see no further questions thank
you thank
noesi okay thank you very much thank you
chairman committee members and I thank
representative Manion for filing the
bill I believe I am the constituent who
asked for this to be filed so I am um
here to speak on support of House Bill
506 I'm not here as a lobbyist I'm here
as a concerned citizen who saw firsthand
how
um violation of due process and an
individual's rights with the return due
to the return of firearms and ammunition
related to an order of protection
a close uh personal associate of mine
had their firearms and ammunition uh
confiscated related to a false claim of
abuse the claim was a blatant abuse of
our domestic violent laws which are
meant to protect our most vulnerable
citizens but instead it was used to
retaliate against an individual who
refused to give money to a family member
and I'm going to clearly outline what
happened day one was the argument and
money wasn't given
no further conversation it was over the
phone day four a complaint was filed
with the local police um that they were
felt threatened the police investigated
and found there was no um it was not to
be uh
credible day 10 another complaint was
filed with the with the um the
courts so then the firearms and
ammunition were
confiscated d 31 is the court hearing
the courts now dismissed the case
because it's not
credible the police notified the person
that they had found that the court was
the case was dismissed and they were
waiting for notification from the courts
for the return of firearms and
ammunition it never came 2 weeks later
the individual went to the court and was
told they had to have another
hearing day 78 is a second
hearing again no notification was given
to the courts um to the police that the
com that the uh Firearms were to be
returned it took day 100 before the
firearms and ammunition were
returned over two months after the court
case was dismissed 69 days to be exact
before property was returned in a case
that was investigated by the police and
the courts and both found not to be
credible a clear case of gross abuse of
our domestic violence laws and yet it
still took 69
days House Bill 506 would ensure a
timely return of firearms and
ammunitions it lays out a two-day time
frame for a request of background check
and a 10-day decision from the
Department of Safety this is a 12-day
time frame that would have expedited the
days the only thing missing from this
bill and I would ask for an amendment
um is a time frame that the courts must
notify the police of a return of
firearms or return of property I would
request that you add another two days
that once the uh Department of Safety
has made their decision and told the
courts the courts have two days to
notify the police department that they
have to return
property that's my testimony and I'm
open to
questions thank you um when the person
went to the court court hearing the
second one the one they to get their
property back at that time did the court
issue an order in their
favor yes well the court ordered um a
dism the case was dismissed the first
one yeah but we they had to go back and
ask for uh their firearms yeah it took
two seconds and they said yes go ahead
you can have them back but we never
never received the notice so what how
did the notice finally end up getting
there just to showed up or snail mail
they said it would come through the
snail mail so it took that long so from
the time the judge during the two-minute
hearing said yes you're correct you
should have your property back it took
an additional 22 days 22 days for that
order to get there I see all right thank
you and the other thing is ties up our
court systems yeah that are grossly
understaffed and it ties up uh police
storage sure so did did the person get
an order from the court that day in
their hand no no so have they got an
order they could have brought that order
to the police department themselves if
they could but the uh judge said it
would come but through the snail mail
sure okay representative share um just
as a point of information for everybody
the court there's no automatic procedure
that's for executive session okay that
you can edify us well I was hoping to
everybody yeah go ahead go ahead uh
there's no automatic procedure in for
the once a case is dismissed a DB case
was dismissed for the court to notify
people that they can come pick up their
property that's just not part of what
the court does so you this legislation
would help that yes yeah I think it
would help and the the police department
was notified that the case was dismissed
but they couldn't release the firearms
and the ammunition without the L without
the letter
right any other questions no thank you
very much thank
Stone good afternoon John Stone clamont
New Hampshire I was the original Prime
sponsor last year of uh this bill under
the previous number which was 1339 and
this bill is strictly about establishing
time frames for a court proceeding to
the do the return of firearms uh one of
the issues that was brought up last year
from some of the state holders that from
a law enforcement aspect of it that
contacted me the evidence room gets
filled with a lot of people's Firearms
they sit there the court case is either
been null Prost it's not a domestic
related case each agency decides whether
they're going to give guns back and how
they're going to facilitate that through
their own local policy I believe it's
the state police's intention that they
would like to have a get out of jail
free card that if it's given to them
they will freely give the guns back but
only at a court order regardless of the
circumstances why the guns were taken
and Captain muzy is sitting behind me he
was involved in I believe the
subcommittee we ran last year as well as
the language of this bill uh along with
some other stakeholders that are behind
me there was a consensus among all of us
this was a good bill when we brought it
to the house it did pass the house it
did die in the Senate uh something to
remember is these Firearms are
individual's property in some cases have
either monetary value some significant
monetary value depending on what the
items are and evidence rooms are not
really generally policed all that well
they're kind of stored uh
you know they could develop rust they
could get banged around that could
decrease the value of someone's property
uh once a person is uh no longer
prohibited there's no reason for the
state to be exercising control over
one's property and that was to rectify
this is to make sure the courts have
established time frames of which to
return the firearm so that's it's not
out there three four five months I'm
willing to take any questions and I'd
recommend that this uh bill is ought to
pass um what is your position on the um
the suggested amendment by the citizen
regarding the two days I think the uh
that would be excellent the other uh
issue that was brought up by Captain
excuse me deputy chief Allen of the CL
Police Department who was yesterday is
that they were just concerned that
they'd be a party when this order would
be filed so they would would know about
it so it didn't slip through them
because this bill specifically says the
department of safety if issued by the
court is to do the Nicks background
check yeah they just don't want to feel
like they were outside the loop so that
they would be included as a party to
safeguard any duplicate issues that may
arise would there be an issue I if it
allowed the court to hand a notice to
the plaintiff that they could just take
to the police and say Here's my order I
wouldn't want to speak on their behalf
that I would think that a court order
issued in hand is has the same uh you
know Authority as suspenders mail them
one too correct yeah and I know the
court system now uses the portal system
you know some of those old folks
remember when that used to be all
written and now a lot of it's
electronically uh produced submitted
we'll ask the state police thank you any
questions for anyone else see none thank
Banger Ray Banger anyone sounding like
Ray
Banger okay next U Captain M did you
you don't have to I just no just uh good
afternoon chairman and members honorable
members of the committee I'm captain
muzy from the state police I'm in charge
of the Justice information Bureau which
includes the uh the permits and
Licensing unit for those that I I don't
know so I did uh testify on this last
year we did work on um some some
language changes and things and I think
just to answer your question about um
the potential amendment of um a an order
in hand or something like that I from my
perspective and I don't want to speak
for every department but personally as
as an officer and what I would be
looking for that would be great um as
long as we have an order signed by a
judge that we can rely on to say we have
a signed order here to release these um
it would certainly be more expedient if
it were in hand um so I I I don't think
the police would be opposed to that
theory and I think I understand that and
I don't want to speak for the court the
two-day window by which the court would
have to notify the department that seems
somewhat reasonable to me um um I assume
an email or something would suffice I
don't know how rigorous the process
would need to be to uh to make that
notification and I can tell you that
from the police's perspective yes we
would be looking to empty evidence rooms
um more quickly so that that goes to
that effort as well thank you uh I feel
like if we do the inhand order the
two-day thing is really doesn't matter
then at that point they can just
literally mail the other one but if they
have it in hand they have it in hand
certainly thank you further questions
for the
captain seeing none thank you anyone
else wish to testify on this bill who
has not done so seeing none I here by
Clos public hearing we will reconvene at
here
e
I'm open in public hearing on House Bill
551 I invite the prime sponsor to
uh good afternoon committee good
afternoon uh chairman Roy uh I'm rep
John SS I am not the prime sponsor I am
the co-sponsor the prime sponsor is out
sick today okay I'm just going to
introduce the bill I'm hoping there you
have a few more people that want to talk
to it my my under my understanding of
bill of course I signed on to it is that
to stop and get rid of some duplication
if they're already doing it at the
federal level there's no reason why we
need to do it at the municipal level as
far as getting
approval selling firealarm so well I'm
not going to go into too much more but
that's my gist of understanding of this
bill and I'll take a question or two if
you want but I'm not sure if I can help
you out too
much uh that's I don't believe necessary
I think we understand the gist of it is
there anyone else here is going to
testify on yeah there's a few people so
thank you all right thank you committee
the chair calls
gon thank you Mr chair honorable
committee uh for record representative
Henry
gon T an District Hillsboro County so
what this does it repeal the requirement
for a second licensing or permitting
that no other small business has when
they have to found no other business has
to apply for a second permit through
their town or
municipality uh it's a second layer of
administration that does not increase
safety and what it does do is it slows
down the ability for the small business
owner to be able to begin their business
FFL compliance is already the first step
and with FFL compliance the police chief
or department has already been notified
so this second layer does not increase
safety by notifying anybody
else uh it removes a requirement which
can only lead to a delay in the business
um and is pre uh and can be prejudiced
in its execution there's no fiscal
impact of passing this and there's no
safety impact of passing this it simply
streamlines a process that's already
there by getting rid of a redundancy at
the Town level that can be abused at the
Town level thank
you thank you for um testifying about
about this
bill are you able to take any questions
no so it's my
understanding to run a Firearms business
you have to obviously get your federal
firearms license and um they check where
you are to make sure you're in
compliance with zoning and so
forth what does the town license
do my understanding is that the town
license only gives the town an objection
to or lengthens the process and may
include a fee you're correct and the
that the FFL already checks on those
things and already notifies the police
departments thank
you yeah all right thank you that's
all uh the chair calls representative
Stone
good
afternoon John Stone clamont serve as
operations manager for Black Op arms
which is a federally Firearms licensed
business in addition I serve as the uh
National firearm act compliance officer
and I am testifying in support of this
bill uh as a sponsor it said this bill
is going to be removing a kind of uh
archaic requirement for municipality in
New Hampshire to issue a license to sell
pistol and revolvers uh it really serves
no other purpose than to really put a
double notice on the police department
that already knows that you're in
business selling Firearms it's part of
the process of obtaining an FFL you have
to have an inspection done before the
license is issued and part of that is
the uh the zoning requirements for your
municipality have to be met with that
being said if there's an issue there the
uh process stops until that situation is
rectified um I know we have some rural
areas of New Hampshire and we also have
some you know metropolitan areas that
zoning is very clear there's nothing
getting put up or put out that they
don't know about uh I don't know if
there's a fee for some municipalities
for the license I know it's kind of a
hassle sometimes to track down your
local Chief to get him to uh issue you a
license when yours is expiring and your
continuing business uh currently there
is no other State Licensing for firearms
dealers in the state of New Hampshire is
strictly a federal firearms license uh
the feds do know where you are they know
your premise because you can only be
liced by an individual FFL for each
business that you have if you have two
businesses you need an additional FFL
both of them need zoning done prior to
them coming to see you U as regards to
some of the other things the uh sponsor
already hit on it that federal law
already prohibits selling to out ofers
even as an unlicensed individual uh I
think this is a good bill and I think uh
you should support it fully you know if
anybody has any questions I'm willing to
take them
could you tell us a little um if you
know the history of this law in other
words why why did was this enacted if we
already needed a federal law or is this
from before A Time when the federal U
government licensed firearm sales I'm
not sure Mr chairman of the legislative
history of it it would lead me to
believe that it was a time when maybe
some places weren't doing so much with
zoning and uh issuing out permits and so
forth this was a way that if you're in a
smaller area I think to notify the law
enforcement officer that hey we're
running a business of firearms you used
to have a lot of uh home businesses
today they've kind of gotten away from a
lot of them there still there's a few
popping up here and there but a majority
of them are all brick and motor which is
what the ATF seems to uh like to deal
with more than home business for a a
period as my understanding the FF uh
excuse me the ATF wouldn't even approve
uh if you didn't have a building that
was physically separated from your home
is that true I remember some people
actually going out of business I believe
there was a push I believe uh I think it
was either 10 or 15 years ago to try to
reduce that but they still allow anybody
that had a license out of their house to
as long as they're still purposes to
make money and to be in business not to
increase your personal collection so the
ATF really it even says it on the
application when you apply for a federal
firearms license that if you're not in
it to uh be a business and make money do
not submit the application gotcha and um
finally for me it says repealing the
license to sell pistons and revolvers um
what about long guns long guns were
never an issue it was always pistols and
revolvers so I could open up a business
tomorrow with my FFL and sell rifles all
day long and shotguns all day long and I
wouldn't have to worry about it but if I
want to sell a pistol I have to get a
town license that would be my legal
understanding of it yeah okay thank you
uh represent Sher uh was it the
intention of this bill I I see that the
bill repeals RSA
1598 correct uh the third paragraph uh
of that bill prohibits uh a a a sale of
a weapon to a person who is a convicted
felon uh was it the intention of this
repeal of 1598 to do that it's already a
violation of federal law for prohibited
person in other words the federal
government would take action on that
individual such as they do
now can I give you an example sure we
have individuals that'll come in they'll
purchase a firearm they'll end up being
delayed the statutory time frame elapses
they then receive the firearm they come
back as being a prohibited person for
either felony conviction or domestic
violence conviction misdemeanor the ATF
will then arrange with that individual
to either meet them or for them to
surrender the firearm back and then it's
up to the ATF if they want to pursue
charges which sometimes they do often
they don't okay thank you so the the
portion of the statute that would be
struck prohibiting the um sale of
firearms to felons would not prohibit
the sale of firearms to felons I mean it
would not the Felon would be committing
a crime by purchasing a firearm because
it's still legal it's just duplicative
okay thank you I have a question yes
Representative no you have a question so
my question is the the thing that we get
is that you know the fact
that the state has at one time when I
was a young rep fairly
young I had an argument with with with
the chair a chair about we have no I I
said we have no firearm laws in this
state and he pointed to this law as
being the one yeah we do we got one law
so so there is one law you can the law
specifically says the people have to be
known to you if you're going to sell it
so if someone sends to his na sells
something to his neighbor we have a
state law that says you can do that if
he doesn't know him personally and
doesn't get
identification so that being the case
can he be prosecuted if we don't have a
state law can can the state do any
prosecution or or is it like people
going into a school that the feds have
to do it because because we don't have a
law so actually so what's the effect of
taking this law out of the state as far
as New Hampshire actually takes it a
step further with it's a felon in
possession of dangerous weapon or deadly
weapon that includes Firearms so that
law is an independent law from this one
also F follow I'm just wondering what
you think it's 159 well no it's chapter
159 I believe that section applies to it
well this is it's quite a long chapter
okay thank you
yeah thank you Mr K and thank you for
taking my question um I just had a
question around the zoning bit so when
um municipal when you're saying that the
um the feds are basically checking the
zoning restrictions when they're issuing
these licenses are there is that like
just whether something is zoned for
business or not or do M municipalities
specifically zone for gun business gun
related businesses what it is is the ATF
for concern that you went to your local
Municipal agency got all their approvals
all their go-aheads because if you don't
then that creates an issue for licensing
for the premise uh as far as if you're
asking like maybe in a in a school zone
ffls are actually exempt from school
zones under federal law so that's not a
real big consideration what it is they
want to make sure if you lease say
someone's leasing a property from
another person they want to make sure
that individual also has a signed copy
and notification that you're going to be
running a Firearms business out of their
rented premise if you don't own the
building itself so the zoning is a very
key point to it so essentially so so say
I wanted to open a gun store I would
still have to go go to the like the
local municipality and go through all
the normal like things that you would do
to open a business and then get licensed
through the FFL so this is really just
like this isn't removing the
municipality's ability to already have
like jurisdiction over like absolutely
not you have to still comply with the
zoning
requirements any further
questions seeing none thank you thank
thank you Mr chair Jr hle for the record
dun Barton um currently the secretary
for the New Hampshire Firearms Coalition
as well as the former State Rep um I
would like to address a comment that was
made by one of the members saying that
this repeals the ability or the repeals
the the prohibition on sale to a person
who has a felony that is under
1597 not
1598 that will remain on the law so that
question that was raised in the prior
discussion is n and void um this is a
completely redundant system to what is
currently in place between the business
requirements if you want to establish a
home business in our zoning laws and
what is done with the federal government
to get permission to sell firearms this
is a pro business Bill there is no
reason why we should take take firearms
and the sales of firearms and make it
more difficult than any other Home
occupation if someone wanted to cut hair
at home and that was their business they
would have to still go to the town to
get permission to set up and establish a
business in their
residence just like you would for the
Firearms the only difference is you have
extra Hoops to jump through for firearms
that are different than any other
business foot traffic car traffic to a
home FFL is going to be a lot smaller
than let's say someone who's running a
hair salon out of their
house one two three times a month
someone might show up that's a viable
business in New Hampshire we currently
have and all of these businesses are
listed you can go to the ATF website
right now and find every FFL in the
state of New Hampshire as of this
morning there are 606 of them they vary
by the number of town okay some towns
have a lot some towns don't have any
that is not because there's a there's
fewer there's less demand in the town of
conquer or in the city of conquer than
there is in the city of Manchester it's
because some places make it very hard to
get a
business set up to be a home
FFL um we would ask that you would
support this bill this is a pro business
bill that will make it easier for
businesses we are ready Are a large
firearm manufacturer and distributor
relative to other states that makes we
are also one of the safest states in the
nation if not the safest state in the
nation and I would like to continue that
proud tradition thank
you
thankk
yeah thank you Mr chairman
um could could you just clarify what
what RSA did you say we there was
confusion about or there it was so one
of the one of the prior questions asked
was does this repeal sales to felons
that prohibition it does not that is
1597 that is not impacted by the bill
the bill repeals
15988 um I believe it's 8B and 10 if I
recall and then then any references to
those so sales to felon still stays on
our books prohibiting sales to felons
Ste says on the books thank
you representative Harry
gather um I just want to clarify because
I'm reading RSA
15910 and it says relative to penalties
for sale without a license required
under RSA
1598 and then the other piece of that
when it talks about um
Rel relative to wait minute I find where
reading so that is a class B felony
today and this bill would repeal
15910 okay but there is a federal
prohibition and there is now there is
also a state prohibition about selling
to someone who is a prohibited person
right you can't sell to a felon that is
okay 1597 prohibits this and it says
whoever violates the provisions of this
section shall be guilty of a class B
Muse thank you for answering uh
answering my question um what it looks
like we may be losing if we were repal
1589 is the requirement that the
firearm uh shall uh be delivered to a a
a purchaser not personally known to the
uh or who doesn't or who doesn't provide
uh you know clear evidence of their
identity so um you know obviously we
would want to know who these people are
correct so
um this I'm aware of a case down in
Brookline from a number of years ago
I'll attempt to answer your question
with it with a set of events someone
listed as a store owner a firearm for
sale on a 3x5 card that person as the
store owner was subsequently convicted
just because they were advertising for
sale which is what the statute says it's
not about transfer at that point gun
owners tend to be very um religious
about making sure they don't want they
don't want their firearms hand ending up
in the wrong hands so so they tend to go
overboard to make sure if they're going
to sell one privately that they know
that the person is not prohibited
because it's in their self-interest to
do
so does that answer your
question um a little bit it looks but it
does look like that provision would be
disappearing from the law so in other
words where would that position it it
would it would change from something
that's in statute to best practice
representative where does it where does
it take that that away please 159 15 15
no 15910 if I may right any person who
without being licensed here in provided
right the license is is the license that
we're going we're doing away with um
advertises or exposes for sale or has in
his possession with the intent to sell
is
guilty this is not about selling a
firearm to the wrong person to a
prohibited person the way 15910 is
written it's about the advertisement of
a firearm which is what has been used in
the past to convict people of of
felonies I would argue under 1598 d a
I'm not sure the Attorney General is
doing this but
1598a
says um the Attorney General shall at
least once annually file with the
Secretary of State a summary of all the
laws of each state of the United States
relative to the purchase of pistols and
revolvers in such
States I could do a 91a but I'm pretty
certain that doc that document doesn't
exist and hasn't for a while we have a
lot of these extraneous requirements of
departments that are out there that say
you have to do X Y and Z that aren't
getting done so yet one more reason to
clean up the books I'm not sure that you
you quoted the the statute that would be
disappearing in uh 150
1598 uh according to the way that it's
worded so in in Roman numeral 3 what it
says precisely is no pistol revolver or
other firearm shall be delivered to a
purchaser not personally known to the
seller or who does not present clear
evidence of his identity that would be
disappearing if we if we simply repeal
this
1598 license to sell Roman
3 correct it also shows up in
15910 right which is part of the repeal
any person who without being licensed as
herein provided sells advertises or
exposes for sale right or has in his
possession with intent to sell pistols
revolver shall be guilty of a class B
felony that is simply about right just
the mere advertisement is considered a
felony there's no transfer taking place
under 15910 that's also repealed under
the statute correct so where in our laws
does it still say that you can't
transfer a firearm to someone you don't
know it would not be there at this point
right because that's under 159 983 okay
all right but as I said earlier firearm
owners don't tend to want their firearms
in the hands of the wrong
people um they respect what a firearm
can do because they don't want it in the
hands of the wrong people they tend to
make sure that the people that are
buying it are not prohibited I can I can
tell you that it to me one of the
strongest arguments against an earlier
bill that we heard um which was
requiring mandatory background checks is
that
we are already prohibited from
transferring Firearms to some we don't
know so you're taking that one argument
away and relying only on we tend to be
responsible I I feel like that's a
pretty slippery
slope can you there's nowhere else in
our law other than this place right here
well so you're prohibited under Federal
and under state law for selling to
someone who's not a qualified right is
not a known selling or prohibited a
prohibited person so if you if you sell
to a prohibited person you're already
violating the law it is a punishable by
a felony level offense so that's not
going away which means the burden is on
the the person selling the item to make
sure the person that is receiving the
item is not prohibited okay thank you
any further questions uh that you
already heard the answer to well I'm
trying to figure out I mean where where
you just now said that we have a state
law that says you are prohibited from
sale to a felon and I'm just wondering
where that is 1597
and we haven't repealed that one here
correct that is not part of the bill
I'll take a closer look at that thank
you very much sure thank you for your
you going to wave off okay anyone else
wishing to testify on this bill was not
done oh
what oh Mr
simin thank you Miss Mr chairman and
members of the
committee uh I am a federal firearms
licensee my name is Jay simpkin resident
of Nash New Hampshire held an FFL for a
shade over 40 years over 30 of them in
nsha I have a personal interest in this
bill it will save me a $10 license fee
every 3 years 10 to1 in postage every 3
years and about an hour of my
time as others have
indicated
this repeal will simply clear up a
redundancy the redundancy exists because
when this law was enacted in 1923 and
with my prepared testimony I provide you
with a copy of the relevant section of
the 1923 law there were no federal laws
regarding Firearms the first such
federal law was the Federal Firearms Act
of 30 June
1938 which established lure at the
federal level for firearm
dealers that lure was rolled into the
gun control Act of
1968 and I provide the actual sites to
statutes at large in which series are
published us
laws so removing the state license this
license by the way has nothing to do
with municipalities
police Chiefs issue it on behalf of the
state it's not a city of nashal
the the repeal of 159
col8 simply removes a redundancy a
redundancy that could have been removed
15 years ago or even a little more but
the application for an FFL and and I
append an extract from the most current
version requires that a copy of the
application go to the chief law
enforcement officer it simply was a way
in
1923 of enabling a police chief to know
who in his or her
jurisdiction was retailing
handguns that's what it was intended to
do that's what it did but since the
federal Authority require a copy of a
new or renewal application for an FFL to
go to the chief law enforcement officer
there is no reason for the state
license um I have prepared testimony
which I will hand over and I'm more than
willing to answer
questions see no questions thank you for
your
testimony the chair calls representative
McFarland
oh no you saying me I I misheard your
there thank you Mr chairman uh I think
that most of the points I want to make
uh have already been made so I'll be
very brief uh first of all uh I want to
State for the record this testimony is
representing My Views and the views of
my constituents uh in graph 19 is not
made on behalf of any private employer
nor should it be construed to represent
the views of any of my employers uh the
FFL uh system as you've heard uh already
provides rigorous oversight and this is
uh an unnecessary um set of statutes
that are being repealed here uh and I
know there was a question that came up
earlier having to do with um the the
clause in RSA
1597 um and I would just say that for
the the committee's reference uh that
which will remain does Clearly say that
no person shall sell deliver or
otherwise transfer a pistol revolver or
any other firearm to a person who has
been convicted in any jur in any
jurisdiction of a felony uh and goes on
further uh I support this bill and I
would ask you to recommend it for OTP
thank
you thank you so anyone else wishing to
testify on this bill who hasn't done so
so now hereby close the public hearing
we reconvene at
4M
e
afternoon I'm opening executive excuse
me the public hearing on House Bill 609
and I invite the sponsor to introduce
the
bill oh did you find my p no I didn't I
think
it's thank you Mr chairman to the
committee my name is Sam farington and I
represent Rochester Ward 4 I know it's
been a long day so I'll try to be brief
I'm here today to introduce House Bill
609 the purpose of this bill is
straightforward to fix certain loopholes
in New Hampshire's preemption statute
the granite state has a tradition of
respecting the right to defend yourself
in 2003 the state enacted RSA 159
section 26 the preemption statute what
this did it prevented political
subdivisions so towns cities counties
from enacting certain or I guess any
regulation restriction on the possession
or the sale the use of
firearms and so this ensured uniform gun
laws throughout the state of New
Hampshire in other words your right to
defend yourself did not change depending
on whether you lived in Rochester or
dairy or conquered the only re relevant
law was decided by the
legislator the preemption statute gives
authority to the to the state right now
state agencies are exercising that
Authority and that's a problem it's a
problem because state agencies are
telling certain employees that you can't
defend yourself while on the job your
right to defend yourself should not end
when you step foot into a government
building or when you go to work for
state
agency this is a problem
House Bill 609 addresses this by adding
Clarity to the language and removing the
vagueness it does this by adding
agencies as you can see in the bill to
the preemption and also restricting
certain rules as well as the ordinances
and laws and regulations of the language
and with that I thank you for your time
and I'd be happy to ask any or answer
any
questions thank you we we may have a few
questions just give me a second as I go
over the the bill what was the impetus
for you bringing this bill did you um
have a an employee you don't have to
give me any names or anything but was it
a state agency employee that felt that
they were being wronged or yeah there
was a a tragic instance that led to a
death and uh another representative will
speak on that okay
great any questions for the
representative what is what is the
age have
question go ahead thank you Mr chairman
um I'm hoping you can answer a question
for something I've been trying to find
for several
years and I apologize cuz he and I are
sharing the bill right now do you know
what what the legal age is in New
Hampshire for a person to have um pepper
spray and or maybe like a a taser or is
there an age yeah I didn't mention that
but um this bill would also add
self-defense tools so pepper spray taser
stun guns other defense tools to the
I could get back to you on the age
requirement um but that would be added
to the bill okay so my my I'm sorry
follow up Mr chairman so the reason for
my for my question if it helps clarify
what I'm asking is say a person uh 16
years old say they they waitress right
it's Saturday night they made a lot of
money that night they're walking into
their car obviously they don't have a
firearm um or even some so if they
wanted to have say pepper SP in their
keychain
I was under the impression that there
there was like an age limit for that and
I wanted to do away with that but I
couldn't find it to see what it was and
that's why I'm curious if you you know
that my understanding would be that that
would be set by the state by the
legislator and under the preemption
statute cities and towns couldn't pass
further regulation on that matter okay
thank
you thank you for your test oh
thanks for taking my question under
under your bill would a school uh be
able to prohibit any of these items like
stun
guns the bill prevents political
subdivisions from regulating uh the use
the the school
board a school district would be a
political
subdivision so a school followup so so a
school district would not be able to ban
these
correct okay obviously federal law would
you see no further questions thank you
thank
afternoon thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee for the opportunity to
testify in strong support of House Bill
609 I'm representative Donald McFarland
of orange I'm here representing my
constituents in the towns of Alexandria
Bridgewater Bristol Kan and dorcha and
field graft and gron Hebron and orange
my testimony is not made on behalf of
any private employer nor should it be
construed to represent the views of any
of my employers our state constitution
grants the general court the power to
legislate on matters affecting the
rights and safety of our citizens how
House Bill 609 reinforces this
constitutional mandate by ensuring that
the regulation of self-defense tools
remains within the purview of our
elected representatives this centralized
approach promotes consistency and
accountability in our laws without House
Bill 609 there's a risk of regulatory
fragmentation where various state
agencies and local and Municipal
entities could impose differing rules on
the sale possession and use of
self-defense tools such a patchwork of
regulations would create confusion among
citizens and law enforcement potentially
leading to unintentional violations and
uneven enforcement across the state New
Hampshire has a proud tradition of
respecting individual
liberty and that includes the right to
self-defense by retaining that
regulatory Authority within the general
court this bill ensures that any
legislation affecting these rights
undergoes thorough debate and
consideration by The People's elected
representatives this process safeguards
against Hasty or unilateral decisions
that could impinge and infringe upon
constitutional rights in conclusion this
is a prudent measure that prevents
regulatory inconsistency protects
individual rights and enhances Public
Safety I urge the committee to support
time see no questions thank you for your
test
good afternoon former representative Jr
hle dun Barton speaking on behalf of the
New Hampshire Firearms Coalition the
bill before you um is a continuation of
something that was started 20 years ago
20 years ago the state legislature
realized that having this Patchwork
quilt of laws or rules at different
towns would be problematic
you don't want to have to go from
Amherst to Milford and then find out
suddenly you're violating a town
ordinance this bill was put in 20 years
ago to address that that we will have
statewide uniform laws relative to
firearms in
200 11 that was further expanded to
include um knives as part of this policy
because we were aware at the time that
certain uh retail establishments near
the the town of Hampton in particular
were were regulating which which knives
could be sold and not sold so this
passed overwhelmingly and in a in a
strongly partisan House and Senate this
passed obviously but it was also signed
by Governor Lynch realizing that we
should have uniform laws relative to
Firearms tools firearms and tools um the
bill before you expands this to other
non-lethal self-defense tools
I I have three CH well four children
three boys and a girl um my oldest or my
daughter is is no longer a minor but
when she was a minor as a dad I would
let her have pepper spray if she was
going out and walking the dog cuz that
was a good way for her to protect
herself and we live in a pretty quiet
Town dun Barton has 40 residents per
square mile so it's a pretty quiet Town
relative to like
Manchester and I thought it was a
prudent way for me as a dad to let my
daughter take our dog for a walk same
thing is true we might want children who
are out walking or biking or hiking or
any of the normal activities that we do
in the state to be able to protect
themselves but there's no laws today
that make sure that there's uniform
regulations across the state relative to
these non-lethal forms of
self-defense so this bill expands it to
non-lethal forms and itemizes a list the
bill also closes this loophole about
agencies and someone asked the question
before what about that we had
unfortunately a very tragic accident
with officer hos um and that was due to
a policy that was established between
DHHS and Dartmouth hos Hospital which
was running the state psych psychiatric
ward we should be careful when we start
disarming our citizens it should not be
on the application that you have to
voluntarily give up your rights as a
citizen to be an employee of the state
we should fix that now is a good time
time this fixes it it makes it clear
that the legislature not the state
because the state could be
misinterpreted to be an agency so it
fixes state to General Court particular
and it does that to make it clear that
we should be doing any regulations
regarding self-defense tools by Statute
not by agency rule or by
contract and then it goes through and
adds these non-defense sorry these
non-lethal um tool tools that people
routinely use to protect themselves to
this list of self-defense tools and
that's what it does I would ask that you
would find this ought to pass um and I'm
here to answer any questions if there's
technical questions on either the
history of the bill or what the bill
does thank you um I have a question so
agencies
yes you're not allowed to have u a
firearm within the Prison
Walls it'll if the if the commissioner
says okay um all my prison guards you
are not allowed to have firearms inside
the walls that rule would then be null
and void by this statute is that not
correct I as written correct and I do
believe prisons are one area right the
the the inside domain of the psychiatric
ward is is areas we might want to
include in this statute that says right
there are regulations in this narrow
area relative to carry okay courts as
well courts is already covered under
statute that's under 159 I don't know 18
192 somewhere in that domain I I don't
have it in front of me but would so we
have two conflicting statutes though it
would say that no state agency well the
the Judiciary is its own Branch so yeah
but so it it and and I'm going to quote
I didn't bring the copy of the bill up
right
um
uh except as right um except as
otherwise spe specifically provided by
State Statute so in the case of Courts
it's already a state statute says you
can't do this right yeah or or you're
not allowed to carry there I think the
point is that if you wanted to do
something relative to prisons I would
ask that you would delay action on this
bill today and I can help you craft an
amendment for that one um because I do
believe you have an argument to be made
about who can carry behind the locked
doors within the prison yeah right I do
believe the personnel that work at the
state prison probably already do carry
but I don't know all the rules about the
state prison and it's not for us to to
to um tell them how to do their job in
that area I believe that once they go
beyond the locked area and they're in
the general population area they don't
carry firearms either okay um yeah I
think that I think that it would do uh
well to think and and we could expand I
think it's section
15919 I'm going for memory um that is
the the prohibition relative to
courts if if well the court I know is in
statute so if this says other the
statutes then it should be fine we don't
have to address it right no but I'm just
saying you could expand that section if
you wanted to do something about the
prisons yeah uh Courthouse Securities
15919 so you could broaden
15919 to write state agencies and state
facilities in one section okay further
questions representative um Sher
uh where I I know uh Bradley House was
shot at the uh at the uh at sorry at the
uh the the state hospital correct where
was he located was he within a lock
facility or in the outside no no he was
the security for the building at the
metal detector he was at the front door
okay making sure people didn't make it
into the facility with anything that was
metallic in nature and he was prohibited
by a contract from protecting himself
what I wanted to know thank
you yeah representative
bogert thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you for taking my question would
this have an adverse effect on local
jails C in the local jails they don't
permit guns within uh the lockdown areas
also so the same as prison so I I don't
so I don't outside of cities I'm not
sure what towns actually have jails I
think it means counties count okay
counties and as I said if if you choose
not to act on this bill today I think we
can probably put something under what is
15919 relabel it from Courthouse
security or broader and we can put in a
section six that addresses prisons and
jails uh represent that is not the
intent for the record that is not the
intent of the bill to take care right
right uh represent n thank you Mr shair
and thanks for taking my question um I I
think I I might have misheard you but um
in this bill it has the language of or
other self-defense tools and I think I I
heard you say something that it was
itemized could you just direct me to
where it's itemized what that actual
definition of of other self-defense
tools would be so when you write a this
has to do with statutory construction
when you write an itemized list if you
don't put an or other type thing that is
my question is someone comes up with
something newer than a pepper spray
device right it's a Kimber makes this
pepper spray spray looking pistol okay
it's a pistol it has two shots of pepper
spray this little red cute thing works
really well I guess I've been told
anyway is that a pepper spray device or
what is that right what if it falls
outside of this category so when you
make an itemized list that is the list
that's what the legislature said they
said a B C or D and that means EFG are
not included so you tend to put a clause
or similar so that it shows the
intent okay we could and one way to
construct this and we did talk about it
was to construct a term at the beginning
of one 5926 which is definitions and
then you can define an itemized list and
just call them self-defense tools
thereafter
thanks with regard to this um other
self-defense tools so let's say I work
at the DMV I like to carry a sidearm
they say you can't now I can because of
this saw but it also say other
self-defense tools well if I like to
carry a baseball
bat can my boss say
no well is it a when does a baseball bat
become a self-defense tool right that's
why it was it was broadly right
because we it says and we added right
trying to find unintentional C no no no
we added knives years ago right um in
there is a knife a switchblade is a
knife an auto opening whatever the
latest and greatest everyday carry knife
is right or or they all under the broad
category of
knives clearly a knife would be a
self-defense tool what if it's an auto
forward I think it's auto forward
opening is the latest craze in the knife
Community um does that fall under a
special category of knives I mean even
Massachusetts got spanked by the Supreme
Court in a 90 decision about things like
I believe it was pepper spray and tasers
in a case about a dozen years ago or so
because they were overly restrictive in
Massachusetts and the Supreme Court in a
90 decision told them no you can't do
this these are these are clearly ways to
defend yourself I I we left that
language or other in there because you
don't want you don't want someone to
come along I I would call a baseball bat
that's more of a tool to go play Little
League not than it is a self-defense
tool I I understand um what I'm
concerned is obstinate employees telling
their boss well today this is my
self-defense tool what can you do about
it
um all right we'll think about that one
we have we have some days any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
time the chair calls representative
Layon
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Erica Leon I
represent the town of Derry which is
Rockingham
13 I'm in my third term now and when I
first came in I thought everything was
really straightforward talking about the
state and political subdivisions then on
my second term I was um added to jel car
The Joint legislative administ joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules
and I have to tell you the onion of
different layers of government really
opened up to me because I didn't really
understand just how much agencies are
involved in the state just how many
people work for those agencies and how
often they can set policy for the people
who work within those agencies
themselves without any legislative
oversight um it I believe that when this
bill was first passed the intention was
that agencies are considered part of the
state but if you haven't had that
experience about sort of seeing those
differences and those definitions it's
kind of hard to capture it when you're
doing a Big Bill like this in order to
make sure that you are getting rid of
the patchwork of
rules so I want to zoom back from that
and talk about one of my neighbors um I
had some neighbors down the street from
me um really didn't like the Second
Amendment really didn't like
self-defense really didn't like any of
that and we talked a lot they knew that
around then was when I had gotten my
first gun and we started talking and
they was working a job at one of the
state agencies where she ended up having
to go alone into situations where she
felt
uncomfortable it didn't take long from
them for them to start realizing the
value of self-defense and start
realizing the value of tools that would
allow that young woman the chance to get
away from a bad situation she didn't
have that opportunity at her job with
the agency and so she quit the job
because she was worried that if she
continued doing that job she'd end up in
a situation where she was killed or
worse so I think it's critical to make
sure that we can protect people that
work throughout the state work for our
agencies and make sure that we're not
denying them the tools that they need um
if their brain and all other other ways
to protect themselves fail because quite
honestly sometimes we run up against
very bad people and when very bad people
want to do something to you it's good to
have a tool to stop them might be pepper
spray that might be your level of
comfort it might be some new electron I
defense weapon that isn't a taser but
works in a different way which is why
it's nice to have the language about
other self-defense tools or it might be
a firearm if that's something that
you're comfortable with and you
understand the consequences of using
that I think that it's very very
important that our plow drivers aren't
left to be defenseless if they end up in
a situation where like that
Massachusetts plow truck driver about a
20 years ago decided to plow in
somebody's car and there was a really
big
confrontation because right now without
this somebody who's working for the
Department of Transportation can be told
that they can't carry a
firearm and they might be left in a very
very vulnerable situation I think that
this is a really Common Sense expansion
of um of a law that just protects the
people of New Hampshire allows them the
same opportunity to protects as every
other Granite Stater and whether or not
you personally want to use any of these
tools I I find it uncom conscious B that
we would say that somebody's going to go
out work for the state work for an
agency and they aren't allowed to
protect themsel with effective tools so
I support this bill and I hope that you
will support it as well I would be very
supportive of an amendment to outline in
statute things like the prison system um
where we know that we should not be
having people walking in with Firearms
let's make sure that beyond that beyond
that metal detector nobody's Waltzing in
and they're able to make rules about
which which employees are there
but I have to say that when I heard the
news about what happened to officer hos
my first thought was my God I hope that
we didn't prevent him from protecting
himself unfortunately we did we don't
know if he would have made the choice to
carry or not we don't know if he would
have had the time to do anything but he
was disarmed because of the actions of
the state and we have a chance to fix
that
now for the for the record he he
wouldn't have had time there was a State
Trooper standing right there so it was
it was tragic but it did call to
attention the fact that they were um
forcing them to be defenseless so thank
you um any further questions for the
representative seeing none thank you
thank
orus thank you again Mr chairman
representative orse Pittsfield Chai
Chester and thank you committee so the
point I was going to make basically was
uh dealing with remote situations and
that points just been made so thank you
very much I I think it's been covered
thank you thank you and by that you
meant like the plow drivers and stuff
out on the roads yes sir absolutely yeah
my wife uh works for Dees she's been in
uh various remote situations not only in
New Hampshire but in different states
where she's gone out and uh got in a
situation once with a bear and once with
a pack of coyotes and she said time to
start caring four-legged criminals are
sometimes much more dangerous thank you
botin hello everyone honorable committee
members I'm presenting myself as a
concerned citizen I stand in strong
support with Bill house uh House Bill
609 New Hampshire's Live Free or Die
motto embodies our commitment to
personal Liberty we have championed
constitutional carry lives and sharing
our citizens rights and responsibilities
remain
protected House Bill 609 recognizes that
self-defense extends Beyond
Firearms by legally protecting tools
such as stun guns tasers and pepper
spray we ensure all residents can defend
themselves as our fifth President James
morau stated the right of self-defense
never ceases is among the most sacred
and necessary to Nations and to
individuals thank you for your
time thank you for your
evening uh thanks for listening to me
today again for the I don't know how
many it's time but um joean and gunar is
of New Hampshire uh we support this bill
I I agree with some of the concerns
earlier we should just fix those little
little changes but uh just remember this
isn't legalizing you know the use of
free reain you can do whatever you want
with stun guns Peppers we have laws on
the books if you use a pepper spray or
if you T if you use a a spray on someone
it's a misdemeanor if it's used Comm in
the commission of a crime it's
considered a felony if you use it on a
police officer it's considered a felony
uh with stun guns but apparently it's
only a misdemeanor if your pepper spray
them minut it's not in a crime but I'll
let I'll let that alone
um also uh the uh the concern about
other devices um we' we heard Bill we
heard Bill earlier about uh you know
paper weights I'm sorry breast Knuckles
uh slug shots and blackjacks being uh
legalized again um this would then if in
if that would become legalized this
would mean that the state would be the
only person with preemption to deal with
those laws and they can address them
this way we avoid the patchwork like
we've heard so many people talk about
another interesting thing that I think
is it's not a new idea uh RSA 918a it's
on line 21 on
page one of one um two it's uh basically
it's it's a a person agreed to violation
May petition the superior court and seek
remedy remedies under that RSA uh that
can lead to reasonable attorneys fees
and costs if you are actually in the
right and if you're in the wrong because
it's a a malicious lawsuit that was
brought about for bad reasons then the
jurisdiction the town locality or
municipality would be eligible to
recover court costs uh also if there is
a bad faith effort made say if someone
knowingly says oh I know it's legal to
have but we're going to make a law
anyway that's a bad faith um violation
this would give the someone standing to
go and have a remedy of between 250 and
$2,000 of a civil penalty for bad faith
violations plus that person would also
be then have to pay the fees and
attorney's costs of the uh the the case
so that's not new we have that for other
for other violations of uh the
preemption law and other things but uh
this would add these into that uh as far
as uh also other self-defense tools
isn't just what I mentioned before that
we discussed it could be something that
may not be invented yet I'm not a big
sci-fi fan but I'd love to have a phaser
that' be cool um but you
know another debate for another time but
I think that if some something new came
along something that was maybe
completely harmless didn't even cause
pain just say we came up with something
that could freeze someone in space for a
moment not you know I don't think it's
happening anytime soon but if that
happened wouldn't that be something nice
to have as a self-defense tool you know
we could actually have the state then be
the one who's preemptively allowed to
take the rights to regulate it like hey
you can't just do it on random people
we'd obviously have laws for things like
that but it would be the state doing it
not this NW workk of localities so um
I'd be happy to take any questions and
if not I got to go to a birthday party
my little girl is turning 16 today
so I don't see any um you can wish your
daughter happy birthday and part of the
committee I'll tell her you said that
thank
you anyone else wish test fin this bill
who has not done so seeing none I hereby
close the execu excuse me the public
hearing and we will have a 10-minute
recess to caucus and then we will
sessions
e
all right okay with that I'm opening up
okay I am opening the executive session
56 and I am recognizing
representative rhs to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move itl
for House Bill
56 I'll second that seconded by
representative appr would you like to
speak to your
motion sure
um I don't really know what has changed
from from when we heard this bill last
year I do know we have some new members
but I didn't hear anything different in
the testimony except for the fact that
there was not an exception now for
somebody that maybe felt their life was
you know in danger or was maybe being
threatened by somebody uh the reason was
given that the person might not be
trained I don't it's nice to have people
trained but it certainly is not a
requirement um and and given this it it
there's just nothing about it that I
think is good and I really don't think
there's much more I can say other than
we already all know representative Pro
would you like to speak to you a second
I tend to agree with that I was really
concerned about about that if somebody
filed a restraining order on somebody
there was an active threat that they
still had to wait the 3 days uh the
perpetrator has the ability to wait
three days get a gun and then go after
her uh or him whoever it may be but uh
not having the ability or a provision to
make that happen
um I don't see
it thank you um I would add the FBI has
something called it time to Crime um
records they keep and and that's the
time from a fireman's purchase to the
time when they actually use it in a
crime and I was unable to find any uh
numbers uh from New Hampshire where a
crime had been committed within 72 hours
of being purchased so there's that
further
Muse I'll be uh opposing the the
committee recommendation
um what this bill really tries to do is
to toughen statutes that keep Firearms
out of the hands of people that our laws
say already should not have those
weapons um what we're doing is we're
expanding it to uh to Private Sales that
don't involve um a licensed Firearms
dealer and requiring that a licensed
Firearms dealer be part of that process
we're not not blocking anybody's access
to
Firearms um uh all we're asking is that
people pass the same type of background
check that they would have to pass if
they purchased the weapon from the
dealer um this is not an unreasonable
thing uh to do uh this is a common sense
Public Safety measure uh the bill was
written extremely carefully um with
input from a lot of different folks a
lot of different constit encies um we
went out of our way uh to address some
of the objections that we've heard uh uh
when previous uh uh I I won't say
previous versions of this bill but when
when other bills that tried to do the
same thing were introduced um and we
think we satisfactorily met those things
so I I think the the issue is is when
you're looking to kill a bill like this
you'll always find a reason to kill it
but there are far more reasons to pass
this bill than the Killer
thank
you further
discussion see a none ask cler to call
the rooll motion of Flor is in
experience
legislator Vice chair roads yes
representative
PR yes representative Lal yes
representative devoid yes representative
pck hat yes representative saor dwan yes
representative bogert yes representative
Harriet Gite no
representative muse no representative
Newman no representative Murphy no the
clerk votes no representative Newell no
representative Shear no chairman Roy
ch's yes
87 by 8 to7 the motion of itl passes
meis Muse will you be doing The Minority
Report yes I will
okay um if you could get it to me by
next uh Tuesday afternoon please please
one and with that I close the executive
session I open the executive session on
House Bill 207 I recognize a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move
ought to pass on House Bill
207 I'll second that seconded by
representative PR would you like to
speak to your motion oh thank you Mr
chairman
um this is just this is not a obviously
a firearm um my understanding is this
you know these are at this point
basically collector's items um I know
there's been some back and forth with
the Senate you know passing inter or
passing and doing different study
committees um so we're we're going to
pass it again and send it back over and
see what they
say thank you representative um Pro
would you like speak to your second I
um defense weapons
um I'd rather get hit by a blackjack
than get shot right so I mean somebody's
attacking me and I'm in a spot that I
can't carry a gun because somebody had a
a rules or it wasn't convenient and I
had one of these um
it would be nice to
have right now I can use a aspon
that's more powerful than the
blackjack or the knuckles so I don't see
why we can't bring these back and take
them off the list um again there's not
many of them around um and and again
truly is mostly col collectors with
these thank you um I I would say this um
um I can I can carry a a samurai sword
um down the street I can carry a samurai
sword wherever I want I can carry a
baseball bat I can carry an electrical
weapon that will knock you out for a few
minutes I can carry spray that will
blind you I can carry all kinds of
things but I can't carry these and I was
particularly moved by the testimony that
pointed out the history if you think
about it for a minute and look at this
list of things these are things that
were carried by long showman and
fishermen and who would get their
paycheck when their boat came back in
and go to the to the bar and and tear it
up and hit each other with blackjacks
and and fish killers and that's really
what those things are for is killing a
fish um this is a bygone error type of
thing and it's not protecting anyone uh
I don't even know where you would get uh
brass knuckles I I last night I looked
online I couldn't even find any place to
order them so um it seems silly that we
are outlawing the thing that David used
to kill Goliath 4,000 years later so um
I'm going to move and vote um off to
pass representative Murray thank you Mr
chair um I agree that uh it's silly to
ban these things and I also think it's
silly that we keep trying to pass this
bill and so I've voted for it the past
two times but this time I'm going to
vote against all to pass motion because
I don't understand why we're going ring
around the rosie with the on
this maybe maybe your changing your vote
will be what it takes I don't know did
you have your hand up represent
Muse one thing I would like to say about
this bill is um I think all you have to
do uh is go out there and Google uh
blackjacks assault breast Knuckles uh
and you will literally get hundreds of
cases that show up so these are not uh
injuries that we're reading about from
the 17th century in Dusty books um these
are things that we can go online when we
can read about now um uh there was a
case uh last year uh a woman was sitting
at a at a stop sign a guy tried to hi
had tried to carjack her car uh reaches
in through the window um hits her with
brass knuckles in the face um uh if you
if you if you look for this thing online
I mean the damage to the face of this
woman um uh was something you you know
you wouldn't believe so the these are
not um you know fun little antiques that
people put on their shelves there may be
some people who do that but there are
people who actually use these weapons
they take them into bars they take them
into situations where uh where
frankly um what they do is they
essentially serve as a a force
multiplier for for somebody's fist when
I hit somebody with my fist um in these
days I I I I don't generate anywhere
near as much power as maybe I I used to
but the damage is pretty minimal I go
and put on a pair of breast Knuckles uh
and I can break somebody's orbital bone
um I they can they might need 50
stitches for their face you know these
weapons are designed to take that force
and to and and to multiply it and they
cause Grievous injuries and there's
evidence of that if we care to look for
it and and I think one of the things
that we shouldn't do with this committee
is tell ourselves nice little stories
like this that basically are not true uh
there's a lot of evidence that these
weapons are harmful and that they should
stay prohibited in New
Hampshire I can likewise Google for
hours and look at Hammer attacks and and
knife attacks and all these other I mean
Britain right now is is riddled with
knife attacks and they're discussing leg
making a license to buy a steak Knife um
so that that doesn't seem to help so um
representative
who
pette I was just going to say um as far
as a force multiplier I mean you don't
need to use one of these items to be a
force multiplier um you know I once
broke somebody's orbit with my boot you
know and if I wanted to hurt somebody
here you know I could use my fist I
could use that stick I could use a gavel
so any of those other things could be a
force multiplier you know and I don't
have to go out and specifically buy any
of those so I don't know that you know
that would be more lethal than the
other thank you uh representative Sher
yeah I I wasn't going to say anything
but I've been provoked now um you know
when we're talking about knives steak
knives and things like that they have
other uses
the things we're talking about here are
brass knuckles don't have other put
aside The Collector item issue brass
knuckles don't have another use
blackjacks don't have another use and
and that that's the difference uh second
I um back in the 80s again this is
somewhat ancient history but I
represented a number of people who were
charged with uh who did significant
damage to people with blackjacks and uh
with brass knuckles uh some without
getting into the details some were
convicted some were not convicted but um
that's my
concern and your point is well taken but
I would go back to um a sword has one
purpose um and so does a firearm and we
don't make those illegal and as a matter
of fact the Supreme Court has said that
the electric weapons and weapons like
that in common use fall under the Second
Amendment um whether we like it or not
it it it is the truth so I it doesn't
make sense to me that we some things are
legal and some things are not when the
more devastating things are legal um it
doesn't make any sense as I said that
that the weapon that Davy used to kill
Goliath we make illegal um see no
further discussion ask the clerk to call
the role motion on the floor is ought to
pass Vice chair
roads yes representative PR yes
representative LEL yes representative
devoid yes represent representative Pat
yes representative saor dwan yes
representative bogert yes representative
Harry Gite no representative muse no
representative Newman no representative
Murphy no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no representative
87 motion carries um who was going to do
Report representative here at gaite um
Tuesday and I'll I'll do the majority
report I have to argue with anyway with
that I close the executive session I
open the executive session on House Bill
352 and recognize myself for motion I
move inexpedient to
legislate I'll second that um thank you
I will speak to my motion um
the polling
place issue to me is
again it it's about this thing we put in
our head about geography um you know 100
feet here I can 100 feet there I can't
it it doesn't it doesn't make any sense
um people that say well it can be
intimidating I haven't I didn't hear any
cases nor has anyone come forward to
testify that there were cases of
intimidation in the Hampshire with with
Firearms at a polling place um it's
against the law to to Menace someone
with a firearm already police are
already there they would make an arrest
for that the case the fact that someone
sees a firearm and becomes nervous um
that's that's um unfortunate but we are
the United States and this is New
Hampshire and we do have firearms
so making someone have to disarm
themselves to stop off and vote
especially if they're going somewhere
else afterwards it just doesn't make any
sense that we're going to take away one
right so that you can do another and
expanding the um absentee voting um
absolutely no um we've already expanded
that quite far enough as far as I'm
concerned would you like to speak to
your second representative Pro uh he
covered most of it but I
when the sponsors said it well if you
feel uncomfortable without your gun you
can do absentee voting and I just say it
goes the other way around
too but I agree it shouldn't be
unarming yeah and I would I would just
add schools um are sometimes polling
places um and that was raised as you
know as if the children well first of
all generally when there's a polling
going on the school's closed second of
all federal law says you can't carry a
firearm into a school unless you have a
license um and the people that still
have licenses have gone through
background checks and to buy a firearm
you've had a background check that's all
further discussion representative Murray
thank you Mr chair um I just wanted to
State for the record that while I
personally don't believe that your
second amendment rights disappear when
you go into a polling place I will be
voting um as my constituents have
requested against this bill and with my
caucus
thank
you see no further discussion ask the
cler to call the rooll motion on the
floor is
what go
ahead I think one of the one of the most
sacred things in this country uh is
being able to go into a polling place uh
and vote
um what this bill does is address a long
history uh in this
country of voting intimidation and what
it does is it lowers the risk of voter
intimidation when I introduced a similar
Bill four years ago we actually amended
the voter intimidation statute uh
instead of the gun statute uh for this
bill because what this what this act
does and and what the risk is is that
people will be
intimidated the I think given the level
of of division that we have
uh in this country and given the focus
that so many people have on voting and
the voting process one of the things
that we've already seen our po po
workers have been threatened uh people
have stood uh PE armed people have stood
near Dropbox dropboxes uh in places uh
like Arizona um this is behavior that we
are seeing um we've actually seen it uh
in Manchester in the 2020 election
so the bottom line is does it does it H
has it happened a lot uh to to this
point I think it's happened enough uh to
justify some precaution and uh and I
think this is a a sensible precaution uh
that we should take and it's a sensible
precaution that some states have been
taken taking taken since
1776 uh when the Constitution was first
written um I think there's a there's a
general recog nition that no right uh is
absolute and if you look at article 3 of
the New Hampshire Constitution one of
the things that you'll see is that we
basically we basically say that so there
are situations where the right of people
to be uh to be safe um and and to be in
a
situation where they can you know
exercise their rights
safely does um at times
uh o overcome an individual right um and
this is a and I think one of the things
that we have to do um
is you know when we make law is we need
to achieve some sort of level uh of
balance and that balance does not always
mean that if it's a second amendment
issue it tips over every other right
that people
have so that's where I am on this and
that's why um voting against the itl
recommendation thank you further
discussion representative Sher uh being
the man of compromise that I am I think
the the the obvious compromise here
which was raised initially by the chair
uh is that we change the word carry to
clearly display uh and I think that that
meets all the concerns here my
understanding is a procedurally that's
going to arise in another context so uh
uh I'm going to vote itl on
this thank you further
discussion see a none ask C to call the
rooll the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate Vice chair
roads yes representative PR yes
representative LEL yes representative
devoid yes representative pette yes
representative saor dwan yes
representative bogert yes representative
Harry gther no representative muse no
representative Newman no representative
Murphy no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no representative
Shear no chairman Roy chaires yes I
thought representative said he was going
to vote
[Laughter]
it I was that
[Music]
close sometimes itls are confusing on
which way you should vote I found that
out early the the motion of inexpedient
to legislate carries by a vote of 8
to7 and uh who will be writing The
Minority
Report uh representative Muse uh same
thing Tuesday midday please and um I'll
majority yeah these are all regular
calendar of um with that I close the
executive session I open the executive
session on House Bill 381 and I
recognize representative um rhs for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I would
move ought to pass for um HB 381 but I
would like to yield to uh the chairman
to just do the brief discussion as I was
focusing on an amendment sure um I'll
second it and then I'll speak to
it so I seconded that um this this um
Bill presents an an interesting um
legal perspective for us it it discusses
exempting Firearms um built in in the
state of New Hampshire and sold within
the state of New Hampshire from the
National Firearms Act and it's according
to the sponsor it's designed to elicit
um or provoke the federal government
into uh trying to enforce force
their oversight through the 14th
Amendment um in what we would say is a
overreach by using
the um the laws that they have to get
into Commerce the interstate commerce
clause where they have
overextended their reach into so many
things in so many states um a good
example was brought up with regard to
Farmers and and their ability to control
what you grow in your property within
the state so while this is about the
Firearms Act it's more than that it's
about the government's Federal
government's overrate using the um
Commerce Clause and the sponsor feels
like it
would get that case moving um whether
that happens remains to be seen but
we're going to support it further
discussion representative share yeah I I
I'm just as a law professor I'm not a
big fan of uh of passing legislation
purely for the purpose of of uh as
articulated to challenge the commas
clause or anything else so um I'm going
to I think I'm going to vote um against
this
proposition thank you um yeah I I tend
to agree but then I thought you know how
else do you get him to take a case if
you don't make one so um see no further
discussion I ask Court to call the role
motion of floor. to pass by chair rhs
yes representative PR yes representative
LEL yes representative devoid yes
representative pette yes representative
saor D yes representative bogert yes
representative haret
G no representative muse no
representative Newman no representative
Murphy no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no representative
Shear no chairman Roy
chot yes 87 by V of 8 to7 the motion L
to pass carries
um who's going to write
the who BOS
okay no I'm not sure yet representative
shabor D would you like to maybe write
the report on this the argument for
it yes sir okay I'll give you the
guidelines and tell you how to do it
thank you you get it uh well I would
assume you know how to take your legal
brief and shrink it by
110% um okay with that I closed the
executive session and I open the
executive session on House Bill
506 and I
introduce recognize myself to introduce
a motion of ought to
can I get a second oh I'll second that
sorry that's all
right done your I got my paperwork Spiel
here first and we're going to pass it
out here pass pass these down I don't
know if that's enough they gave me a
whole stack of them
please so I'll speak to the um the bill
and the amendment the bills we passed
this bill last year it seeks to um
return the property to people in in a
quicker fashion than they're already
having to go through some people we
heard wait months and spend thousands to
get their own property back because of
the way it's set up so this would seek
to speed that process up the amendment
that was brought um it simply says upon
receipt of a proceed response from the
Department of Safety Court shall
immediately issue in order to return
property now there was discussion two
days three days I didn't want to get
into it because the courts set their own
schedule they can determine immediately
um how they want hopefully it means
they'll do it as soon as they possibly
can and they will mail a certified copy
or a copy to the police department and
they'll call the petitioner and say
there's a copy available here at the
court if you want to come get it if they
want to come get it and drive down and
get their stuff that day with a
certified copy from the court they can
or they can wait for it to come into
mail it just gives them an option to get
it faster
um and that's really
discussion see none out ask the clerk to
call the role and the motion is to adopt
the amendment number
H Vice chair roads yes representative PR
yes representative Lal yes
representative devoid representative
pette yes representative subor dwan yes
representative bogert yes representative
Harry Gite yes representative Muse yes
representative Newman yes representative
Murphy yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Shear yes chairman Roy chot yes 15 z uh
at this point I would move off to pass
is
amended seconded by president Murray um
I don't think there anyone want to have
any more discussion I think we covered
what it does um seeing none I'd ask
clerk to call the role the motion is
asked to pass as
amended Vice chair roads yes
representative PR yes representative LEL
yes representative devoid yes
representative pcket yes representative
saor dwan yes representative bogert yes
representative Harriet gther
representative Muse yes represent
representative Newman yes representative
Murphy yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Shear yes chairman right Geral yes 15 15
Z motion carries unanimously any
objection to consent seeing none It
will'll Go on consent uh hereby close
the executive
session and with that I
open I don't think yeah we don't have
the Amendments um I'm going to appoint a
subcommittee on House Bill 6
09 um and I'm going to appoint myself
representative voyd and representative
new and representative
Murray and um we'll meet sometime next
week myself representative the board
board yeah no yeah representative Murray
and representative no what's
that 609 and with that that we're done
for the day thankfully and uh tomorrow's